[Laughter]
hey you guys what's going on i totally
forgot you had that temple of mercy
shirt you haven't worn it in such a long
time yeah it warning is a good shirt
i just when we were when we were in the
car today i just realized we had that
obsidian sticker that we got from that
show where we saw them
and bought some stuff
that was like i didn't even realize that
sticker was in the back seat of the car
all the time so today we gotta go to the
club
so it's not gonna be a super long show
but uh i got
i got mugs in the freezer in there i
think they've been in about 45 minutes
they're probably cold enough for to
frost we'll see
i hope so and i got two different kinds
of beer
got apple pie moonshine
and got some peanut butter whiskey
and uh we'll drink some of this
yeah that's what because i remember you
guys said like last because last week
did was it last week we did the colt 45
and all that situation uh it wasn't
called goal 45 was two weeks that was
two weeks ago yeah yeah last week we did
the um we did the modelo yellow yeah
model was good those were good yeah yeah
so one of you guys said oh you should do
like pumpkin spice stuff so i said well
i'm down for that because i love pumpkin
spice yeah so what was this stuff called
uh modelo what now it's it's like it's
like beer but it's fruit fruit and
spices michelada michelada yeah that's a
lot of yeah that's good man all right
let me um
let me go get the beer
okay
but yeah so we went to
you're gonna put the damn i'm gonna put
this here
you gotta put that
you gotta be fast out there do you want
to uh do you want the same con for me
and you and same one yeah we'll just
we'll both see how how they are because
we got two different kinds like you know
what i mean because i don't know i like
pumpkin spice stuff so
we'll see i even got some i ordered some
pumpkin spice
coffee
and it's um
the brand name is wake the hell up which
i thought was very funny
and the pumpkin spice i guess their
halloween brew is called i think it's
called headless horseman or something
like that and the box is like really
cool so i got some of that and that
shit's pretty good too
i actually wanted some i we went to
walmart today which i hate going to
walmart but yeah we went to walmart
today and um i wanted to get some
pumpkin spice creamer but they didn't
have like a small pumpkin spice they
only had like the big ones and they were
[ __ ] ten dollars and i was like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] so i got one that was kind of
like those what are those [ __ ]
cookies called like that are dutch or
whatever they had so yeah i can't
remember what the what the name of them
are but they had like some creamer for
that and i was like yeah that'd probably
be good in pumpkin spice coffee so i got
some of that instead but yeah so we were
at
walmart and we looked at their beer
selection which was a little
thin i think the only fall kind of beer
they had there was like they had the sam
adams
like oktoberfest whatever i was like
let's go to abc liquor because we passed
one by on the way to the redneck store
it's like oh well there's the abc liquor
right there that we didn't know was
there
so i said they'll probably have all kind
of fun [ __ ] yeah show them that so this
is one of the ones we got this is palm
king
nitro
cold brew coffee
imperial pumpkin ale so i was like ooh
that sounds
delightful
so yeah we're gonna have some of that we
got another kind too but i can't
remember what it is it's not super cold
well i gotta probably put uh i didn't
realize that we were gonna be at [ __ ]
walmart that long yeah note to self
don't ever go shopping at walmart on
[ __ ] friday oh this smells great
everybody was there everybody
and we're like pushing the [ __ ] cart
through the thing and like the walmart
near where we are is a little bit
of a [ __ ] hole
so um i think that smells really good
oh my god it does it smells like coffee
but yeah so the the aisles are like
really narrow and for whatever reason
even though it was super busy in there
they decided oh let's stock the shelves
so every single aisle had like
working i don't blame the workers i know
they're just like being dude they're
just doing what they're told but
so there was just like pallets of stuff
like in the middle and then like
millions of people were there with their
children and it was just kind of like oh
it was a [ __ ] show they're trying to
keep up with demand or a [ __ ]
okay this looks good
oh i like that
i like it yeah yeah it's good i like
that i wish it was that real i wish it
was colder yeah it needs to be colder
but is that real you think real wet yeah
it almost kind of tastes like it's
artificially flavored
well it might be let me see
what does it say
figure a box out jenny
i'm like a monkey because i can't like a
finger
there's not really a lot of information
i guess like you can go to their website
or whatever
stb
stbc beer
southern tier brewing company
four cans 8.6
alcohol percent alcohol by volume
four cans so
nitro
i mean yeah it's good i just kind of
wish like i said because we went to
walmart and it took like
longer than i thought
like by the time we got back
there wasn't like enough time
before the show started to like get in
the
get the beer chilled you know what i
mean i got it in the fridge as soon as
we got home but
it's still the next two that are in line
in the freezer
try to get them colder
good idea
that's good it's uh it's pungent
it's very very strong the flavor is very
strong
smooth though yeah but it's good it's
not not too dry it's a little dry but i
don't taste much pumpkin it's mostly
coffee but that's okay with me
you get a little bit of pumpkin i guess
like on the back end
this weird taste or a little bit of
pumpkin spice i don't know i like it
let me see what it's what it what did it
say
what'd it say
dude it's dark in here i can't [ __ ]
read that
brood and canned by southern cheer
brewing company liquid new york
blah blah blah blah blah government
warning does this have like
oh yeah somebody told me before like
they don't actually have to have
nutrition information on the beer cans
really they don't
so it's got like all it's supposed to be
mostly like a coffee thing because you
can see you probably can't see it but
it's like all little coffee beans yeah
you can kind of see it yeah little
coffee beans cold brew coffee
pumpkin nitro
pumpkin ale
with coffee
yeah that's good not bad
they had another one because i mean they
had a million abc had um because there's
kind of a swanky like abc not too far
from us and they had all of their
fall stuff like out on the end caps
obviously as they would
and so it was hard to pick they had like
a bunch of different ones that looked
really good they had one that was like a
pumpkin spice latte and i was thinking
about getting that but then i saw this
one and i was like oh i think i'd rather
have that guomo cone says it's awesome
micheladas are awesome doesn't feel
right drinking them during the fall
winter months i don't it's not fall or
winter here
yeah but
i like to pretend yeah
i like to pretend that we have seasons
[Laughter]
because i well i like to pretend that
it's fall in winter all the time so it's
like i try not to go outside ever
i just stay in in the air conditioning
and have pumpkin spice coffee and
peppermint coffee all year long so i can
pretend that it's not summer i'm not a
fan not a fan of spring and summer and
that was another thing too like when we
were at walmart i kind of feel like they
didn't have
because it wasn't the only fall beer
they had was the sam adams right they
had sam adams oktoberfest to like
special edition or something and then
they had you know they had angry orchard
and stuff but that's they have that all
the time where are you talking about
walmart yeah warren doesn't really have
anything well well they had a lot of
beers and like it's just you know hard
seltzers but a lot of them were still
the summer flavors i feel like they were
still trying to get rid of all the
summer flavors and like some of those
sounded good but i was just like well i
was kind of more in the mood for like
some fall kind of [ __ ] you know abc has
all the crazy [ __ ] has all the good
stuff like i said i couldn't even pick
they had so many
and i already told them i don't think
you saw it but i saw um i have some i've
got some pumpkin spice coffee that's
called wake the hell up yeah
headless horseman well it's called wake
the hell up because the whole company
like i guess it's like extra extra
caffeine yeah i haven't noticed any like
extra heart palpitations or anything but
it's good though
i don't think we'll drink the next one
in a mug because i think the mug wasn't
quite it wasn't quite cold enough and it
actually sucked
sucked the coolness out of the [ __ ]
beer into the into the mug maybe yeah
because the cans have been in the fridge
much longer right than the mugs have
been in yeah the mugs came out they
frosted but they just
they weren't cold cold enough because i
didn't even remember like to remind you
to put them in but you remember them
last night
yeah but
we weren't thinking about it i've had
mugs so cold you pour beer in it it all
just turns into slush in the bottom
that's that would that's what you know
well see that's the ideal situation
because you can't really i mean
i'm gonna say you can't put ice in beer
i mean you can but everyone will look at
you like you're a weirdo
you can do it in your house by yourself
because this a lot of satisfaction with
nobody judging the michelle well yeah
but that's kind of and i don't know
that's what i mean i guess that's the
same thing and like some people said hey
what like why are you putting ice in
beer but i was just kind of like i feel
like that's an exception yeah
well some people like to put ice in wine
too the michelada was and i don't i
don't think that's weird i mean i know
people look at you like you're weird but
i would totally do it michelada is a way
of turning beer into a into a mixed
drink it's gonna have ice in it and if
salted ribs it was good
honestly pretty much everything should
have ice in it
milk is good with ice in it yeah it is i
know and a lot of people are grossed out
when i tell them that but like my entire
childhood yeah my entire childhood i
would have
um
yeah with my lunch i'd always have like
a little ham sandwich and like a little
ding dong or something like that and not
always have like a big
frosty glass of like ice cold milk like
a spock is moving back there by himself
it'd be really weird if like somebody's
watching this and they didn't know that
pookie was back there and they're just
like oh my god do you have a poltergeist
like spock is moving around by himself
back there
pookie's back there going i love you
[ __ ] i love you
um dave is asking tom what your favorite
uh what your best recommendations for
pumpkin recipes are
what now your best recommendations for
pumpkin recipes ooh that's a good thing
to talk about because we even put like
some of those in our cookbook yeah
because i mean we've told the story a
million times but
we bought like some pumpkins for
halloween and like after we carved them
and like put them in the window and
we're like oh scary scary then we like
roasted them and i was actually they had
all they had pumpkins at walmart today
but i didn't see how much they were
um okay so you want me to answer it yeah
yeah
man i like pumpkin soups
man but um if you can if you can take
you can take um
basically what is pumpkin soup
and uh put chicken in it and have it
spiced in indian spices and make like a
chicken pumpkin curry that [ __ ] was
really good oh yeah
she
yeah that was delicious it's really good
oh i don't remember if we put that in
the book or not and tammy just said the
pumpkin soup in the cookbook is
delicious because yeah it's pumpkin soup
yeah um we have that for like um on
thanksgiving sometimes yeah like as an
appetizer yeah i took that same pumpkin
puree
and just added it
to basically what was going to be like a
like a chicken masala or a chicken or a
chicken curry and uh put that pup put
that pumpkin puree in it and just added
enough
stock and creamer to it to get the
consistency just right and then served
it with basmati rice it was really good
and i had
i think it was just chicken breast cubed
up
and you know you have it uh in
uh
ginger garlic paste a little bit of oil
and uh you know garam masala
turmeric
a little bit of pepper like chili pepper
and just let it sit like that
some yogurt
and let it sit like that for
six to twelve hours
and then fry that real quick in oil the
bottom of the pan
until it starts getting browned
and then um
uh pour your
uh pumpkin puree into it
and then turn it down and simmer it
now uh probably add like chicken stock
to it
and just cover it but just let it reduce
slightly
bring it up to a boil then turn it down
low
cover it reduce it a little bit
taste it make sure your salt ratio is
right see if it needs any sugar it
shouldn't but sometimes you put a little
bit of sugar in there to brighten it
and then um
top it off with cream
heavy cream
until you get a nice creamy consistency
kind of heavy and then um
let that go for like another five
minutes until everything's hot again
until it starts simmering again and then
serve it serve it over basmati [ __ ] it's
real good
yeah i like that very much we should
probably make that again this year
like i said we're at walmart they had a
big [ __ ]
big boxes of pumpkins like on the way
out but i didn't see how much they were
they didn't have a price on them
i kind of feel like the ones we got last
year whoops i forgot that box was down
there um the ones we got last year the
year before at publix
those were a good deal because we got
them like a little bit early i think
they were only six dollars for like
really really big ones
but
i mean
we could grow some of our own i guess
and you could probably buy them it's not
time to plant them though that's the
problem yeah you could probably buy them
like around here i'd imagine
they're selling everything else when we
were driving to walmart today there's a
there's a guy that what's his name ray
raise
produce or raise something and he always
like sets up on the side of the road he
wasn't there today though but yeah he
has like a whole little setup there
that's the thing a lot of people around
here kind of have farms and so they yeah
they were trying to sell um
barbecue ribs pork barbecue on the
corner they didn't last long though the
rain came yeah because start storming
yeah they were there they were setting
up when we like went to walmart but then
like when we were coming back like it
was raining really bad look at looking
at him i think it's that that church
up the road it's uh there's a black
church up there right outside of it it's
got a damn barbecue pit and uh over
there at oasis they said that that's the
[ __ ] best barbecue right they know
how to get people to come to the church
yeah at the church the church is mostly
barbecuing yeah they're like we don't
give a [ __ ] about like all the sermons
and everything like that we just want
some good barbecue so you can sit out
there in front of a little baptist
church and eat your [ __ ] eat your
barbecue
out in their front lawn they got like
corn on the cob and stuff oh no not that
i saw
not that i saw i haven't eaten there yet
oh are you going to eventually
eventually yeah they said it was good
usually if i'm hungry in that area i go
for the mexican food but i'll i'll try
the uh i need to go back to that mexican
place i remember it being good and you
said that it was actually better than it
was yeah it's better than it was
a lot better
that's that little place that's like
half grocery store and like half
restaurant yeah
it's kind of like yeah this is what i
can't believe you chugged that whole
thing already yeah
and he was like before we even started
he's like well we can't can't drink that
much because we have to go out
afterwards well i can drink a beer and
then i was just kind of like well so
don't drink that much i can't i can't
drink i could chug those
that's how i got so [ __ ] up that one
night at the club it was
yeah no kidding holy crap we told that
story right but yeah i couldn't believe
that i have seen you like drink hard
liquor yeah lots of it for hours and
hours all night and not get that [ __ ]
up i mean you've been [ __ ] up but not
that [ __ ] up that [ __ ] you were like
really [ __ ] up because i'd buy one and
then just down the whole thing and put
it down there and buy another one i
would just [ __ ] slam them man they're
so weak yeah sometimes things are weak
i'm drinking them just saying about 12
of them things i don't even know how
many you have i had two
i got one when i first got there and
then i drank that and then like an hour
later i got another one and i'm like i
don't really want anymore so then i
started drinking water and then like at
the end of the night like everybody was
just kind of like is he all right
i think people were buying me stuff too
it's been a long time i think uh i don't
remember
yeah
i know you know people would give me
drinks too
people were giving me shots
they'll do that
well well they don't have shots there no
they don't i was gonna say that you must
be thinking about the oasis people
buying your shots there yeah we used to
kind of get in trouble like that at
ibarr too because like you know we drink
a lot there we get like some red deaths
or something like that have three or
four of those and we're just like really
[ __ ] up and everybody's like hey i
want some shots we're like yeah why not
free booze and then i'm just like oh why
did i yeah next thing you know you drank
a fireball
and then you you drink a red hot
and then you drank a uh
cinnamon oatmeal cookie a lemon drop a
lemon drop
and you're slamming them and you know
that was back when everybody's rich
around here
it was man that was a good year it was a
good time well well yeah i mean what i
can remember of them it was like
[Laughter]
there's always this same group
the same group of regulars in in there
you know it was downtown orlando
and uh they'd show oh hey everybody they
get round of shots for everybody you
know they just walk in and buy a round
of shots
and you're just looking slammed
yeah yeah
still drove home i was able to make it
huh
well that's what i mean that's why i'm
saying that this one time when we were i
did was at memento right was it memento
or what i know maybe it was a saturday
night no this is i don't know it was at
that same place it was at the duke no i
know it was at the same place but i
didn't remember if it was like momentum
or night or if it was like a saturday
night because i know we've been on
saturday night yeah i think we've been
on saturday a couple times yeah because
i think sophie was there and she
literally goes on yeah because she was
the one one of the ones that was like is
he okay yeah not sophie that yeah
another sophie michigan another sophie
that we know no they could tell that
wasn't all right
yeah it was pretty clear they started
moving different
it was pretty clear that you weren't all
right well um our friend tiffany who
bartended
at eyebar uh she quit when they moved or
barbarella
um
she used to joke she's like she could
always tell like when tom was getting
drunk she could never tell when i was
drunk but she could always tell when tom
was yeah and um one of the things that
he would do and like even some of our
friends like kind of make fun of this
too but it's like he'll start
yeah
like he'll start going
[Laughter]
he starts going like that and i'm just
like uh-oh
her main tell when she starts getting
drunk is she starts [ __ ] with me
she starts [ __ ] yeah she starts
calling me a [ __ ]
she [ __ ] starts
[ __ ] cussing me and [ __ ] for not
dancing and then saying i'm [ __ ]
bored and i'm sitting there going huh
what
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah she starts getting
yeah i start getting faces and then i'll
[ __ ]
that was back when uh you know that what
was that bartender's name [ __ ] you just
tiffany tiffany yeah
um i'd [ __ ] call tiffany over and i
said catch me oh you want to go yeah
she's she's picking on me again she's
picking on you
yeah she's okay yeah
cause she knew that she knew the routine
too
when i get drunk because because i can't
defend myself right i can't defend
myself well it's no fun if you don't
like the fact my brains get so [ __ ]
scrambled right that i just go
it's happened a few times on the show
here yeah my brains get so [ __ ]
scrambled i can't i can't fight back so
i just
[Laughter]
yeah she gets a b she's abusive she gets
abusive i'm not abusive when you're
drunk when you're drunk she starts
getting mean to me and [ __ ] and i can't
fight back i'm just at well and then i
and and
[Laughter]
then she doesn't remember it
sometimes yeah most of the time i don't
most of the time like he'll tell me like
[ __ ] i said i'm like really wow that was
good
i don't remember seeing him remember
the whole way back
into the whole way back driving and i'm
just going like we'll be home in a
minute
i just keep it positive i don't feed
into it
it's gonna be all right and then she's
just repeating herself and trying to
pick a fight then she won't even
remember it next morning
yeah i usually don't yeah it depends
what i drink too i kind of feel like i
got worse of that
um
with like whiskey type and i know that's
like it's a little bit maybe like an
urban legend that like what you drink
has a effect but i think it does like to
a small extent
it's like usually like i like whiskey
but usually if i drank a lot of it it
just like made me pissy
like i would get really pissed off and
angry not always but a lot of times but
vodka i'm usually okay
um john smith said i don't drink much
anymore but i've always enjoyed an
absinthe because i'm a hipster prick
i would you know what i wish that i
liked absinthe more because i love all
the
aesthetic of it and i love all the
iconography around it
like a company i used to work for
um that distributed van gogh vodka and
tap 357 whiskey i don't even know if
they still make that anymore
but um one of the other liquors that
they distributed was lucid yes absent i
liked it and so i used to do like um a
lot of promos and stuff like like
posters and menus and stuff like that
and one night this was you do you
remember this is a t-shirt um somewhere
it's got like a bunch of holes in it
it's like all the bottom of it's like
all ripped a really good t-shirt from
lucy it just said loose and it had
really good did you did you design that
no okay it had a real good look like a
horror theme
and uh
and and the the basic motif of the whole
bottle was just a black bottle with
green cat's eyes on it yeah very
minimalist yeah it looked really good
and she put that [ __ ] on and those eyes
would be done over each big old teddy
right right on the tip well yeah because
on the front it didn't even say lucid on
the front it just had the cat's eyes on
the tits that's right and then on the
back it said loose and it was like a
really nice like font like a kind of a
thin font that was all lowercase and it
was like kind of a
like a like a nice absentee green yeah
and um yeah so i did yeah they had
already had the um the logo and the kind
of aesthetic like when i started working
there so like you kind of just had to
like know what their brand was and kind
of do something along those lines
but
we had we went to
um
venue 13 when it was at i don't even
remember where the [ __ ] because it moved
around so much it's at mannequins now
but um
i don't even remember where the [ __ ]
this place was it was one of the places
that wasn't
it wasn't there that long did i kind of
remember it was like
near a was it near a bowling alley i
don't even know but so we were there one
night and they had like lucid sponsored
the night
so they had like representatives from
lucid there because they knew it was
like a goth night so there's like ooh
absent okay we know they knew their
market that's for sure
so they kind of had representatives in
there and they were giving away free
t-shirts i got one like i said i still
have it but it's kind of like torn up at
the bottom because it was a long time
ago
um
and they had the whole thing they had
like the whole setup they had all the
spoons and all the glasses and they had
all the [ __ ] and so everybody was like
well you got to get one you know what i
mean because
you know goff absinthe when the [ __ ] is
this ever going to happen
so we got some and i'm just like every
single time
and i think you know what a couple years
back like friends of ours like even gave
me a bottle of lucid like for my
birthday and i think tom ended up
drinking most of it i wanna like it i
just don't i don't really like
things that are like um
i don't like that uh that flavor like
that um
that anise
that i don't i don't like that like that
licoricey kind of flavor i don't like it
okay well i'm gonna
go for the next one okay this is oh
that's right chai pumpkin latte shy
pumpkin porter porter is that what it is
yeah
so that's like pumpkin tea
yeah
that sounds delicious we'll see
like i said they had a pumpkin spice
latte one too and i thought about
getting that but we got this one since
then
let's see how that one is
oh yeah you like that yeah it tastes
like it tastes like chai i was going to
say is it kind of milky
not really ooh it smells good
it smells like a cookie
it tastes like chai ooh
yeah
it's very sweet but i like it
like don't if you don't like sweet beers
you probably wouldn't like it but i
think it's good it does it does actually
have a really like strong like chair
taste too yeah tastes like tea
just like indian tea
pumpkin i'm into that it's all right i
like it i like it i wish it was colder
well that's what i'm saying you put the
other ones in the freezer though right
they're all in there pretty much
yeah cause i'm not
if i'm gonna drink beer and [ __ ] like
that i want that [ __ ] to be cold well
that's that's true of anything i like
anything like really really cold
but yeah that's good i like i like that
a lot i think i like that a little bit
better than that
but they're like
they're totally different though but
like i said that's real sweet whereas
this one is more
like kind of pungent and spicy
and that one's sweet who made that oh
wait a second oh fallon brewery
where is it uh let's find out
government warning yeah yeah yeah don't
spill it i'm not okay chill out i know
how cans work but you don't have hands
work
you ladies you don't know how anything
works
we love beer that state that looks like
arkansas okay that's arkansas right that
shape i can't see it i'm pretty sure
it's arkansas
cinnamon cardamom ginger clove yeah
indian spices yeah
yeah arkansas okay i think yeah or no
missouri missouri sorry it's missouri so
for you naysayers out there
up in the up in the uh
the hunky motherland of europe saying
that all those american american beer
sucks oh no we have so much [ __ ] i've
never even heard of this brand
never heard there are micro breweries
just [ __ ] everywhere
well nowadays there are nowadays yeah
well that's what i'm saying well and i
kind of feel like
i don't know i kind of feel like people
that would have said that like in europe
are probably all dead now yeah probably
i kind of feel like that was more like a
long time ago a long time ago people's
parents and grandparents thing yeah like
you guys don't know how to make beer oh
no we got all kinds of stuff it's just
that sucks i mean yeah i mean like every
country has
shitty beer and shitty food and stuff
like that and it's like
not everybody
because sometimes i really like
um
some channels that like on youtube that
are british people like reacting to
american things
but um
one of the best ones i think it's called
uh lost in the pond and the guy's name
is lawrence and he's actually good
because he you know is obviously from
england but he's lived in the us for 14
15 years and he's married to an american
so he actually has kind of and he kind
of and he lives in the midwest too like
he lived in chicago and then like he
lived somewhere else so
he has kind of like a better perspective
on it he doesn't have a thing where
because i kind of feel like sometimes if
you've never been here or if you've
never lived here
you kind of maybe think that you have a
perception that everything that
americans oh they all they do is eat
mcdonald's or they eat like that shitty
food all the time or
you know you see things in a sort of
like you know cheese whiz or some [ __ ]
like that and think that people eat that
like all the time and they don't you
know yeah it's it's easy to think that
but i guess that's true of like any
country we probably all have stereotypes
about other countries i'd go over to the
dollar store and get venus sausage and
tea cheese whiz and some crackers and
then bring it back here and eat that i'm
not saying we'd never eat it but like
violating but it's like every now and
then yeah you're not supposed to be i
don't remember the last time i've had
cheese i really don't remember like they
still sell it like obviously people are
still buying this [ __ ] just hit it
yeah
yeah i get that like i said i think the
last time i had cheese was probably when
i was a kid yeah
like we would get you know ritz crackers
and you'd put like a you know like a
pepperoni or some [ __ ] on there it
doesn't require refrigeration so it's
kind of just kind of convenient it's fun
to have and you can sit there yeah well
because when you're a kid you're like
ooh cheese yeah yeah
neat
you know i don't most adults don't eat
that right you know what i mean
yes they still sell it and obviously
someone's still buying it or they
wouldn't be making it anymore but it's
not like an everyday
it's not an everyday thing that people
eat we used to carry it in the army
well like you said it's good because
it's it's cheese ish yeah it's it's a
cheese adjacent product that doesn't
need to be refrigerated right
and it kind of gives you a cheese like
experience yeah without actually being
cheesed and it was in a can yeah so you
know really good uh packaging
put it in your rucksack
and i'm going to go out and all it's not
bad no i mean
you just have to manage your
expectations i mean you're squeezing
cheese out of a can
so i think it's mostly whey protein
anyway it's not bad for you it probably
is
well yeah and that's not even what i'm
saying it's just i don't even think
people are complaining that it's bad for
you it's just that it seems like a
ridiculous concept on its face
and i don't know it just seems so
american it's funny because i kind of
feel like that is something
like a lot of the videos that i've seen
with europeans like saying you know
crazy american [ __ ] or whatever
they always they they seem to get hung
up on like cheese whiz a lot really or
easy cheese i guess there's a couple
different brands of it and i'm like yeah
they do sell that in stores but it's not
like that's not like something that you
would eat every day and that's mostly
like a kid thing that's like something
that kids would eat well they got a new
product i got a bunch of it every time i
go down there i buy a pack of it because
it's only like a dollar
it's kind of like mre trees but it's
made by crack by craft and it's a foil
bag
with cheese sauce in it and you can have
either regular or jalapeno and there's
another one i think there's a there's a
a a salsa one which is kind of like a
mexican flavor one
and what you do with it is you cut you
rip the top of it off
and you can put it in a uh
a ramen
okay
okay and make make hot macaroni and
cheese using ramen noodles
all right see that doesn't sound bad at
all no it's good it's a little i can
show you guys if you want to see it but
uh they have it here
and they're just basically giving it
away
but you look at it it doesn't require
any refrigeration
it's it that is military specification
that's something that they would give
you in the army all right it's one of
those in an mre
and it's all whey protein so it's
equivalent to eating like probably like
a half a chicken breast when it comes to
nutrition so there's nutrition in it
and it's just
it's good you know what i mean it's like
hiking backpacking type stuff that's
what i'm saying a lot of that kind of
food like i said cheese was either kids
eat it or people take it like you said
when they're hiking or camping or
something like that because you don't
have to put it in the refrigerator and
it's just kind of like it's easy it's a
single portion and everything i'll show
you right it's that kind of thing thank
you seven lions
long time lurker here you guys are my
favorite pod thank you so much that's so
nice of you any goth fashion advice for
muscular dudes oh tom's got to field
that question
i feel like i pulled it off better when
i was a twig
yeah that well that's the thing i do
kind of feel like i don't know i kind of
feel like it's expanded out some of the
some days but i do kind of feel like a
lot of goth fashion does look better on
like really really skinny [ __ ]
like you had to be like really thin and
vampiric
and um i don't know i'll let tom like
feel that because uh he'll probably have
some good advice about that someone's
asking you about
goth fashion for
muscular dudes
here hold on let me uh show them that
first okay what is that
that's the cheese oh velveeta cheese
sauce okay i can't read it i don't have
my glasses on that's jalapeno show it to
them yeah and then that's that's the
regular
original
and then that's the jalapeno yeah
so you can get those 300 calories yeah
you can get those at like a dollar pouch
at a dollar general store
it's 300 calories 1 380 milligrams of
sodium yeah
doesn't mean anything
you need all that
well i do because i have super low blood
pressure
my doctor 23 grams of salt
22 grams of fat
um
let me see where's the protein
do you want me to hear this
13 grams of protein so that's not that
bad yeah not bad and a total
carbohydrate is 11. so the ratio is
pretty good
honestly
a big ass block of velveeta like melted
with some rotel it's good for you that's
that's some goddamn good uh chip dip
right there some tortilla chips right
[ __ ] yeah so you used to bring that to
the [ __ ] super bowl party
so 300 calories and you've got you got
yourself some protein in there so you've
turned
something worthless like a ramen noodle
dish
into something that at least has some
nutrition in it and that was only a
dollar
so
that requires no refrigeration and it's
a single serving pouch
this
the army mre cheese was basically this
size that's why i said i'm going to try
that
but the army mr e cheese wasn't quite as
creamy as this
you know
yeah it's that's the thing it's like
nobody nobody is arguing that that's
like fine dining or anything like that
but
like you said if you if you're trying to
do like an mre thing or if it's like
survival food if your power is going to
be out or hurricane or something like
that or like i said if you're hiking or
camping or you're going to be somewhere
where you can't really cook or something
like that then those that stuff's really
good it's not
gourmet food but it's edible it's
passable you could take this
a single tin a tuna or or chicken and
put that on top of ramen noodles that
you've cooked which is that's not really
mre because you had to cook the noodles
but we cooked in the field anyway all
right mre means it's ready to eat you
just open it all right but you could
take this
cut the top of it off like this
make a space and put tuna in there and
mix it and eat it just like that out of
that damn bag
there's probably enough room in there if
not you have a you have a canteen cup in
your canteen pouch
that's kind of like people that make
those like walking around uh
nachos where you just like open a little
mini bag of doritos yeah and like put
like nacho stuff from there and like
just eat it out the bag
well what i was thinking of what they
had i was saying well what do they have
a dollar general that would be mre
stuff
and i have it all
what you what you do is you get
chili with beans it's like two dollars
this
and a thing of chicken they had little
cans of chicken
and um
baguette fritos you could throw the
fritos in the bottom of your canned tea
cup
through the put the hot
chili on over that the cheese and some
extra meat
and man that's that's a whole day's
worth of nutrition
yeah that's more than i
should probably eat in one thing yeah
um but yeah so okay so there are a
couple there are a couple food comments
and then there's like the goth fashion
comment which i kind of feel like we
need to address before it gets too far
now uh guama khan said kfc in mexico is
a revelation basically fried chicken
outside the u.s is always awesome i
remember tom mentioned in a really old
episode about how fried chicken was
cooked differently back in the day
um just well you were talking to that
really old guy that said they used to
cook it in motor oil
yeah it was but you could do that before
they had all the detergents and stuff
like that because that problem don't do
it now because that would probably be
super gross that'd be gross
yeah um yeah i don't know if it's good
i've never had it so
so what fashion advice do you have for
muscular goth dudes rather than like
twiggy goth dudes oh i don't know you
don't know um
just wear what looks good on you well
that's the thing like now that you've
started to get buffed out like a lot of
your stuff doesn't fit anymore yeah
well
it's just like uh it's just like with
women too the the better the better
looking women are
the less they actually have to wear they
can [ __ ] wear some cheap ass [ __ ] and
there's not much there and they only
spent [ __ ] 30 dollars and they look
great because it's not the clothes doing
the work it's the fact that she's got a
really nice figure you know what i mean
a lot of those girls are just
basically wearing
nylons or leotard or some you know what
they call like a cat suit and then
there's a couple of cheap accessories
over and some boots and some shoes and
their hair is right and their makeup's
right they look great
because it's the body that's doing all
the work well and i kind of feel like
too that you have to know like i don't
think you have to spend a lot of money
you just have to know like what pieces
will go together
and will look good for your particular
figure
and like i said you have to have the
hair
done right and the shoes and the makeup
and everything like that and then you
can get away with like a really really
cheap ass
outfit if you know how to like wear it
like and combine it with other things
yeah
yeah but like i said that same cheap ass
outfit on a on a 300 pound girl is not
gonna look any good
is well yeah i mean it's not yeah it's
not the same it's the
those girls that have
really nice figures uh uh have it made
when it comes to
outfits well they can wear whatever you
can wear whatever they're gonna look
good well like i said i've seen some
you know i follow a couple of kind of
like
goth or goth adjacent like chicks on
youtube
and
i hate to say it but like if you're kind
of skinny and pale and like
not that old
um pretty much anything you wear is
gonna look good yeah
uh
some other
some other people like me um don't have
that luxury so you really kind of have
to work around you're making a comeback
though
you're making a comeback yeah but still
i mean
the thing about me is that i'm i kind of
feel like if you're kind of tall
and kind of thin
pretty much everything looks good on you
maybe not everything everything but 95
of things are gonna look good on you and
if you're kind of short and kind of
curvy
there's a certain thing there's only
about 40 percent of things that are
gonna look good on you you try to wear
the same kind of stuff that like a tall
skinny [ __ ] would wear it's not gonna
you gotta go the bombshell route
yeah i was gonna say you have to go and
i can kind of see why
um goth girls that are you know shorter
or curvier will usually go in a more
kind of like psychobilly direction
because stuff from like the 50s
like that kind of aesthetic where you
have like the waist where your actual
waist is instead of farther down like on
your hips and then like stuff that
fluffs out like at the bottom i think
that looks better on that body style
you know what i mean because
you know if you have stuff that like
from the 70s where you like you have hip
huckers and stuff like hip buggers if
you're kind of more voluptuous um it
doesn't look the same it depends i've
seen it it does depend it does depend it
depends because there's millions of
different kinds of bodies really good
i'm just saying generally
yeah um
that kind of stuff looks better on like
taller thinner women whereas like
shorter kind of curvier women i think
look better in a more
50s ish kind of cut yeah i think
that i mean and that's what i when you
say kirby though some people might be
thinking fat what you're saying is fat
and and i don't know if that's what you
mean
um
because you don't fall into the fat
category
um
no you can get it here's the thing
she can get away with wearing a lot of
cool [ __ ] that she doesn't because she's
a little bit shy about wearing some some
stuff she doesn't like to show any skin
or anything not really i'm just not i
don't know there's a lot of stuff she
could wear where she would look [ __ ]
super good in but she's like wow that's
too short that skirt's too short she's
got nice legs all right right but i
don't well some of it's too is like
practicality because i just don't want
to spend the whole night like worrying
about it as cute as hell i can't bend
over and impracticality is cute as hell
last time i know that but i know but i'm
saying let me finish i'm talking to pete
i'm talking to the audience
last time we were at
last time we were at the club looking
our friend our friend uh aurora came up
and she was socialized with and aurora's
[ __ ] smoking hot she spent all night
[ __ ] pulling her [ __ ] dress down
and everybody's kept riding up yeah all
the guys are like going god damn god
she's [ __ ] driving all the dudes all
this dude's [ __ ] crazy you know
that's the girl that suspends herself
from the [ __ ] hooks and her shoulders
and [ __ ] like that
no but she knew what she was doing
probably she knew that she knew what she
was doing she was you know she's
she's comfortable in her um femininity
you know she has weaponized femininity
well the thing about it though and this
is what i was trying to tell you is that
there's a difference between look it was
like everybody like we all want to look
good like when we go out but it's like i
have to kind of balance that with do i
like i want to look good on the one hand
but on the other hand do i really want
to spend all night worrying that my
pants are going to fall down or that my
fake fingernails are going to like pop
off when i try to go to the bathroom
it's like so i'm trying to like kind of
like balance the practicality because i
don't really want to spend all night
having to like hike i like pants
i know some of you men you know all the
testosterone [ __ ] are like i
wonder what jd looks like without
clothes i'm gonna tell you what she
looks like without clothes oh my god are
we waiting are we going there are we
when she's we're not even an hour she's
when she's
when she's in form okay when i'm
informed whatever i mean she's gained a
few pounds but she's losing them back
but when she's sucking in form
just look at angela white about like
that angela white that's what she looks
like i don't remember what that looks
like though you know
about like that cross between angela
white and sophie d around that
and that in that she looks good she
looks good
i know but i'm just saying that it's
kind of just kind of like
i don't know
i have a particular like aesthetic that
i like and i'm not real into
like i said i'm not real and i don't
want to be i don't want to go out and
just be like oh comfortable like and
just wear like [ __ ] crocs and [ __ ]
like that i'm not doing that i'm just
saying that i want like a good balance
between something that looks really good
but something that i'm not gonna be like
conscious of all night like when i'm
just trying to have a good time and i'm
trying to dance and stuff like that i
don't really want to think about oh my
god this is falling down or this is
falling off or this is
catching on this other thing or
something like that it's just like i
don't want to be thinking about it i
want something that's just going to look
good without
all of the [ __ ] around it that's all
okay who was asking about tammy said
okay jenny tell us what tom looks like
naked
[Laughter]
depends on when i looked like a lot of
different things over time you know what
the you know what you know what the
coolest thing you know what it's
something that i always like that he has
like the tiniest cutest like tight
tightest little butt
it's like it's
it's super fun oh you can talk about me
naked and like not care but it's like
yeah it's like your butt is just like so
like a little monkey ass it is it's like
a little monkey ass it's like it's so so
funny
don't never wear black slacks to a goth
club don't do it yeah no don't do slacks
never do glasses black jeans is fine you
want to wear something like this
i mean black jeans is fine
with and with boots is even better like
if you wear black jeans
and then like some boots even like some
old school [ __ ] like doc martens or
something like that totally works and
you could wear a band shirt no problem
i mean honestly i went to the castle for
years and years and like dudes would
just show up in that super simple and
like i said i was kind of jealous
because i'm like wow it must be nice to
just be able to throw on a [ __ ]
skinny puppy shirt some black jeans and
some boots and be like hey i'm ready
yeah i don't have to like do anything to
my hair put makeup on or anything like
that florida's hot most of the time so
uh yeah really a lot of the goth look is
is centered around boots
boots and shoes boots and shoes make the
outfits anyway
because um
some of those outfits if you were to
[ __ ] put the wrong boot or the wrong
shoe on them they wouldn't look golf at
all then you put those boots back on you
oh okay there they are
yeah that's what i mean it's kind of
like
it's really hard to get kind of like a
goth look just off the
rack you know what i mean i mean i guess
you can if you wanted to spend money but
we do most goths don't
have a lot of money so i mean and when i
was growing up we didn't have i didn't
even have hot topic when i was growing
up
i have anything all you had was
mail order and most of the time that was
too expensive for me to afford so all i
could afford to do was go to thrift
stores
and find some kind of gothy looking [ __ ]
and try to like either
alter it to sort of look more gothic or
like combine things in a way that was
kind of more organized about now though
yeah that's she's talking about a long
time ago yeah now you can get all that
stuff you go to the castle now and
you're not on [ __ ] point
no sorry
a lot of these girls that you're seeing
posting these little videos on youtube
and they're just decked out [ __ ] just
got this [ __ ] they have their own
[ __ ]
media company and
those girls are on point when you go to
the club they look just like that
that is not an illusion and they buy all
those clothes you can get them they're
not that expensive they just it's calmed
down a lot you just i feel like i have
to invest in it when i was younger
i had to save up for like a year to buy
a corset you order these now yeah the
corsets were
yeah it's
300 i spent 300
on one that was like it was handmade
like the girl like hand made it like to
my
measurements
but and it was beautiful and i had it
for years and years like it was brocade
and it was like it was really gorgeous
and i wore it a lot
but
now you can get decent ones for
i've gotten decent ones for about
i don't know i kind of feel like maybe
sixty to eighty dollars which is a far
cry from 300 that's for sure but you
gotta like make sure because they have
like a lot of cheap ass ones you can get
one for like 20 bucks it just has like
plastic stays in it but those are not
good because the plastic like gets all
you wear at one time one of course it's
supposed to kind of like suck in your
[ __ ] and like you know what i mean and
like
keep you like all [ __ ] contained
and if the stays inside it are plastic
then that's not gonna happen like over
the course of one night it's gonna
loosen like if you're dancing and stuff
and then it's gonna look all [ __ ] up
and like the angles are gonna be all
[ __ ] up okay look at this [ __ ] i found
i i was on my way out
and they had like the little rack there
of all the
little sample sizes for 99 cents and i
saw this and i was like oh my god i got
to get this apple pie this is like
perfect this is apple pie
moonshine yeah and i even told the girl
at the counter i was just kind of like
oh [ __ ]
so we're going to see what apple pie
moves and it's even in a little bitty
jar they know who's like a little
specimen they know who's buying i
[ __ ] love that we drank this [ __ ] in
a jar i love that okay
zach says would bdsm gear count has got
the tire yes yeah
actually matter of fact we're going to
oh
[Laughter]
it was only like a dollar don't get
or maybe two dollars i can't remember it
was like [ __ ] shine man was it
shine
yeah oh yeah you like it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you'll like that you'll
like that you'll like that gram thursday
it kind of resembles a urine sample
ooh it smells nice
just it smells nice but it also smells
like it also smells like just take a
bell to that
nice huh
oh
oh that's good oh that's gonna give me
heartburn though oh
i can already tell oh it's good though
that's good spiced apple
hot
well i was kind of worried because for a
second like it smelled kind of good but
then i was like oh it kind of smells
like rubbing alcohol also
but it doesn't taste like rubbing
alcohol no it's like it's like it's
spicy
it's like you had a dutch apple pie
with the sugar on crumble yeah it's real
sweet it's good dutch apple pie
with um
fire poured over it
i'm glad i got that i wonder if they i'm
gonna get more of that i wonder if they
have like bigger bottles i just like i
said i was looking i was at the checkout
with the beer and i was looking at their
little um they'd make a good spice jar
when that's done i'm gonna put spices in
there
that's delicious it's very sweet it's
got a lot of sugar in it
oh
i like that i like this nice nice it's
um
i like that it's a dessert moonshine
if you ever do like it we didn't know
there was such a thing but no yeah i
didn't well like i said i was at the
checkout like we each got one because i
was like will you choose a pumpkin beer
and i'll choose a pumpkin beer and so we
went up there separate and paint and so
then i was like oh i got to look over
here because they had all the little 99
little airport little you know airplane
style and i was like ooh peanut butter
whiskey i want some of that and then i
saw this little jar and i'm like oh
intriguing and i was like what's that
i'm like oh
that's good i was like they saw me
coming we're gonna get some more of that
i was thinking about getting root beer
schnapps as well but i thought it didn't
really go with the whole theme of the
show but then i thought
you know
spiced apple that's fall what's the
company it's called midnight moon
midnight moon midnight moon moonshine
okay apple pie moonshine
i feel like it's autumn already
that's good
that is goddamn delicious i like that a
lot
it's very like i said it's very apple
pie forward like obviously you can tell
it's very very strong like alcohol
what's the abd on this i don't know
uh
35 so it's not that hot it's not that it
starts 35 35 it's not nothing it's 70
proof 70 proof yeah okay so they've
toned it down
so it's like strong but it's not that
not that strong
it has that moonshine taste to it yeah
oh [ __ ] man yeah
i like that
i would drink a whole well i don't like
it i could drink that yeah i could drink
that big time yeah
i don't know if i'd drink a whole drink
okay so like i said it'd probably give
me a [ __ ] heartburn but you know what
i mean got stuff from muscular guys my
my advice is
remember make sure your shirts aren't
too long
okay
because
if you start getting buff you start to
develop v taper you know kind of a
v-shaped body around the waist
if your shirts are too long it'll make
you look [ __ ] funny you'll look like
a damn
oompa loompa
makes you know
like a [ __ ]
okay so make sure your shirts are not
too long got a shirt for it
um
everything else just kind of falls into
place
you're better off in a way if you're
[ __ ] really [ __ ] if you're really
[ __ ] rocking you got a good thick
[ __ ] upper body good thick chest like
from front to back that thick weighs
that way and you got some v taper
you're better to go off
with a smaller shirt instead of a bigger
shirt so
fat dudes will go a [ __ ] size up on
their shirts to try to hide their
[ __ ] bellies
you might if when you're [ __ ] really
rocking you might want to go a size down
or i could even go farther and
yeah i agree with that advice i would
also even go a step farther as being
like if you're real buff you might even
want to go with just not even a shirt
but like straps straps so you might want
to go with something that's more like
you're going to fall into some [ __ ]
though man with that [ __ ] okay
this is what's gonna happen tom knows
what's gonna happen all right
your gay friends are gonna say [ __ ]
stop shaving because them [ __ ] want
your hair on your back and all these
hairy
they you know they want they [ __ ]
hairy ass bear all right i think it
looks like [ __ ] if you ask me all right
but the gays are gonna [ __ ] if you
got gay friends they're gonna be [ __ ]
why you don't shave
don't listen to them well now it depends
because you got
you know people there people that are
into bears and people not into bears
yeah
some of the gays do not like the bears
gays don't like the gays the gays like
muscle but they like it to be [ __ ]
hairy and a lot of guys who are you know
gym rats and [ __ ] they shave because you
want to be able to see the work that
you've done you know and you want to see
hair hides definition
it
also adds a little bit a few pounds to
you
in terms of like aesthetics it makes it
look like you've got your fatter
it also if you ask me it looks dirty all
right i don't like how it looks i mean
depending on where it is and if it's
manscaped
if you're really jacked that means
you're [ __ ] with [ __ ] anabolics
and if you're [ __ ] with good
anabolics you've got hair on your back
i didn't have hair on my back until i
started [ __ ] around with this don't
even get me started on that you guys i
started taking deanna ball and [ __ ]
groovy i'm gonna let him say it yeah and
then
[Laughter]
i'm on [ __ ] minotaur sauce right now
man [ __ ] uh i'm on a i'm on a
trembling stack this is the first time
i've ever been on trend
and it turns you into a [ __ ] man of
minotaur
and uh you just get [ __ ] hot
greasy
your hair all over your entire body
grows as an at an accelerated rate
um
the androgenic properties are [ __ ]
through the roof he's turning into a
werewolf as well yeah that's what he's
saying you
i did catch myself [ __ ]
watching television getting mad thinking
like sadistic thoughts and [ __ ] [ __ ]
i want to tear that [ __ ]
see this
kill you you know this is what worries
me yeah yeah yeah but it's not real it's
just
you know
it's not real i'm not it's not reflected
at a real person it's it's all it's just
but but i was
i was warned about all this
you know uh i'm not on a lot of it and i
haven't gotten mad at anybody
oh you better not no i will stab you
[ __ ] don't even
it's just
gonna be careful of damn minotaur and
i'm calling it a minotaur because yeah
so did btk yeah
just saying
you hear that dennis
he's back there trenbolon trenbolone
is cattle steroids
it's
it's um why do you do testosterone why
do you do this seriously it's a bowl of
testosterone it's a synthetic bull
testosterone that's [ __ ] had a couple
[ __ ] things added to it the way that
[ __ ] compound the way that molecule
looks is a little bit different
it's
um
it's what you give to uh cattle if you
want them to get
burnt off a lot of [ __ ] fat and
[ __ ] burn up put on a lot of muscle
um
on this cycle i may gain 10 pounds of
muscle and and maybe lose five pounds of
fat we'll see
i don't know i've only been on it for
about uh don't try to kill me two weeks
no
no only been out for about two weeks a
week and a half maybe me and poopy be
over here going
it makes you very strong
it makes you very strong it makes you
heal up very quickly
it uh
you lose all interest in sex
you
um
feel
really good
they say eventually if the if if if
you're on it long enough you'll feel
like you're above humans
uh-oh yeah
you don't need that either we'll see
we'll see i don't know
i don't say you feel godlike
to where you where you look my god tom
why do you want to take this stuff it's
like you're like that already without
all of that stuff you're just amplifying
the worst
of your personality
you can fight it it's well the thing is
is that you don't live on it it's just
something that you do for uh six weeks
and then you come off and you don't if
you if you have to go a little bit
longer maybe you go for a couple another
four weeks or five weeks
to get to where you want to go and then
you jump off of that these are things
that you only do like maybe once a year
or so
look i just thought they're weird enough
they're touch-ups i'm self-aware enough
i know the inside of myself enough to
know that like nobody nobody needs to
give me like god-like powers yeah i
would abuse that [ __ ] god like power but
like i said i already know that i would
abuse that and i'm like i would rather
not have that because i know that you
know i'd probably find some stuff out
about myself that uh that i would not
like yeah uh zack's saying okay so
there's a couple there's a they're
talking about delegation it's i'm i'm
not on pure
trend balloon though i'm on a i'm on a
pre-made trend stack
it's mostly
testosterone something called masteron
masteron's a good compound that hardens
muscle that you do have and then
trenbolone it's not a lot of trampoline
it's it's just a okay amount of it so
we'll see we'll see this also been using
it for this almost tastes like a soda it
does i want to say it does a little bit
it's good okay go ahead and um talk
about that okay so thank you very much
zach
um i'll get back to your question for a
minute because i actually want to talk
about that uh but speaking of fashion i
think the 20s and 70s are my favorite
eras for aesthetics 20s for the glamour
and 70s for that real chill laid-back
style there was some cool [ __ ] in the
70s like i said the girls were very
skinny but if you were very skinny like
some of the fashions looked really good
but they only looked really good on
really skinny people yeah now the 1920s
i'm all about that i really like that
old school
glamour kind of stuff i think i told you
on facebook that probably my favorite
art style is art nouveau um which was i
guess that was was that time period
maybe it was a little bit before i kind
of feel like art
deco
is kind of like the more
known version of that but that's more
angular i liked art nouveau because it
was more baroque and it was just like
very soft like all these angles and like
leaves and i was like i'm into that like
i said my bathroom which is only like
right over there is um
all art nouveau inspired like the walls
are like absinthe green and i did like
all alphonse musha like all that kind of
stuff in there i love that kind of style
but so i'm really into all that 20s kind
of [ __ ] now zach says
here's something i'm curious about how
would you describe goth as a lifestyle
it's not a religion so what's the appeal
um
i don't know like the weird thing about
it is like to me
i kind of feel like
because i grew up before anybody
knew what it was
when i discovered it
because when i was a kid
i was really into
i was just drawn to particular things
and i didn't really understand why
because nobody else seemed to be so i
kind of felt like i was the only person
in the world that was
you know had a crush on lurch from the
addams family or
was into like all this witchy kind of
[ __ ] because i was obsessed with like
ghosts and witches and stuff from from
when i can remember like from when i was
a toddler
and
so
the fact that like i was into all that
stuff and i didn't know anybody that was
into that and then when i was a little
bit older and i discovered
that there was this whole other
subculture of people that were into that
same kind of aesthetic and then like i
heard
the cure and i heard like bauhaus and
stuff and i'm just like oh my god like
there are other people that are into the
same kind of [ __ ] as me it was like a
bit like revelatory because i didn't
know
any of like you know i didn't know i was
a little kid
so for me it seemed like
i don't really know any different way to
be so i guess you could call it a
lifestyle but
i don't know if i really chose it so
much as you kind of grow up and i kind
of just grew up and i was like oh i'm
into all this like creepy [ __ ] and i
love these particular aesthetics and i
don't know anybody that's into that but
then when i found out that there was
this whole other subculture of people so
for me it was almost kind of like i grew
up
in isolation
liking all of this stuff and not
realizing that there were lots of other
people that were into that as well and
so like finding that was like a big deal
for me because i was like oh my god i'm
not the only person and so
i don't really know
like i said i don't really know if
somebody told me hey you have to be like
a normal person i don't know if i could
do that exactly because it's just like
so much a part of my [ __ ] dna all
right
seven says oh my god tren that's the
horny drug well first of all
tren really i wouldn't call it a drug
it's it's it's it it's it's more like a
hormone like a synthetic hormone also
known as a an anabolic steroid all right
um so it's not really a drug and the
effects of it are not very drug-like
um
and
yeah
younger guys
can take that
and sometimes they'll [ __ ] there's
like a burst of damn
sexual sex drive
but that only lasts a few weeks then it
starts to [ __ ] kinda even out into
kind of nothing you know
um as
any time you have weird hormonal about
imbalances in a guy
there might be a kind of a strange
explosion of sex drive from it
i don't really have that because
i'm on i'm older
i'm on hrt
which means that i inject testosterone
to begin with
i've replaced all my bodies or i've
replaced my body's main
hormones with synthetic versions this is
all done through
hrt clinics and doctors you know
supervision
um
i've said it many times to you [ __ ]
okay um you guys man you start getting
into your late 30s you need to [ __ ]
supplement your hormones with
testosterone
that way you don't start getting fat you
don't and and all the damage from aging
really won't
hit you you know what i mean
i went on and around 50.
about 50 wasn't it late 40s
50
late 40s i think maybe no i think it was
50. i think you were 50 or 51. that's
when i went because you're a couple
years older than me yeah i should have
gone on i should have gone on at around
40. well that's what you said that you
should have gone on yeah i should have
gone on then okay
uh then i would wouldn't have to be
playing catch up all the time
you'll just feel a lot better and you'll
live longer
now if you're on hrt
most of these hrt clinics will tell you
well because you're on hrt we don't have
to worry about testosterone suppression
from anabolic steroids why we go ahead
and give you some of these steroids as a
therapeutic treatment put some more good
weight on you
and uh because it doesn't cost anything
it's beneficial for you in your your
situation
so in my situation because i'm on hrt
tran doesn't didn't give me a big burst
of sexual energy it's quite the opposite
if you have too much of a of something
that looks like testosterone in you
you'll actually
uh kind of lose interest
in sex
because most of the man's sex drive
really is kind of it from estrogen
there's kind of like a
balance between testosterone and
estrogen
and when you're taking testosterone and
you're taking when you're taking
testosterone and then you put trembling
on top of that you're going to want to
use a [ __ ] anastrozole which is a a a
an estrogen blocker
because there's masterone in my stack
that i'm doing and i'm taking tests too
so i'll take some hormone blockers to
block the
estrogenic reaction from taking this
stuff
so when i'm on this particular stack
i'm taking
estrogen blockers
which will set pretty much in my case it
seems to sap my sex drive
you know the test test isn't
that
test really isn't what's making a man
feel
uh
uh
driven to have sex past me i think it's
more like estrogen estrogen feels like
really what it is
it's not one thing it's a balance
yeah well yeah the thing about it is i
kind of feel like there's a lot of
things going on with it there's a lot of
stuff going on and i mean i don't know
you know not i don't i don't know i'm
not a man so i wouldn't really know but
it's just like especially for women too
i think there's like a lot more i don't
think it's just hormonal there's a lot
of like emotional [ __ ] going on there's
like a lot of [ __ ] so
i don't know so it could be that too i
mean the thing about it is that i don't
know exactly like you've been injecting
me with some [ __ ] too yeah she does a
little bit of she does
she i don't know what it is but it's
it's 20 milligrams 20 milligrams of
testosterone for postmenopausal women
they should be taking 20 milligrams a
week
and that's just
replacement then you'll do sometimes you
do five milligrams a day of winstrol
and winstrol has kind of a slimming
effect and it also is protects you from
losing losing
muscle mass during this pretty
aggressive diet that you're doing
usually when a person diets they will
lose muscle before the fat
the body is more apt to get rid of that
muscle first
if you're taking wind strokes bodies are
down yeah well they're just well they're
trying they mean well this is starvation
here i'd rather sacrifice the muscle
yeah i get it right but i'm just saying
so what you do is is you give the person
just a tiny bump
of some kind of an anabolic steroid
which will be like the body will be like
i want to take this muscle but i can't
so i guess i'll take the fat
that's and you know and that's right out
of the book everybody knows that that's
[ __ ] anabolic 101.
you can protect muscle mass during
catabolism
which means
you know the starvation basically you
can protect the muscle with
i don't know if i would call when i'm
doing starvation i'm not starving i
still eat it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter yeah it's cannibalism cannibalism
i just don't eat very much that's
cannibalism all right
um well zach will tell you [ __ ] dudes
in the gay scene
if they catch
aids
they can give them drugs now that can
keep them alive forever
but one of the things that they give
them especially in the older is they
when they're older is they'll put them
on [ __ ] testosterone and they'll also
give them
anabolic steroids
and they'll [ __ ] they will never get
skinny and weak looking they'll they'll
look great look at the damn bodybuilder
and they'll they're like well i'm on
test
and i'm on steroids might as well go to
the gym those dudes [ __ ] get [ __ ]
they look great and are they and they're
hiv positive
and they never really die from it
which that's a good thing yeah
well yeah because back in the 80s that
[ __ ] was a [ __ ] death sentence yeah
it was a death sentence back then
and a lot of people died of that right
i'm not now don't take this the wrong
way just because you see a gay guy and
he's [ __ ] jacked that doesn't mean
that he's hiv positive
i'm just trying to tell you you know i'm
just trying to tell you first of all if
you think that there no there are no gay
bodybuilders i'm [ __ ] laughing at you
okay
does anybody think that
i [ __ ] i've run into some jog boys
that [ __ ] were just surprised as hell
that they were gay bodybuilders and i
don't know if that's like wait a minute
where the [ __ ] have you been man they
were probably like
disturbed the founder the founder
the founder trait man
that's a that's a straight thing
the grandfather of [ __ ] bodybuilding
eugene sandow
the [ __ ]
all right
if you look up eugene you look at you
look at eugene sandow
he did a whole show about that all right
well these might have new people
listening to this all right go [ __ ]
he was from the late 1800s all right now
his wife left him for the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that he was doing and some people said
you know
he did
uh uh
he had a strong man routine and he also
did private showings okay
these were for gentlemen that wanted to
do a private so something not just men
mind you these were gentlemen these were
gentlemen
[Laughter]
pay to see you not like your regular ass
man to do a private showing okay uh-huh
and uh yeah we know how that eugene
basically sold nude [ __ ] selfies okay
well yeah and and autographed him and
[ __ ]
and he was a great bodybuilder and
he proved to the world that those roman
and greek statues were real that those
proportions actually were possible and
he would measure those statues and go
yeah i can do it and he did it
he ate a lot of [ __ ] beef and
a lot of meat a lot of chicken and
[ __ ] lifted a lot of weight
zach says i googled sandoz uh nudes once
holy god did he have a great ass said
zach he had a [ __ ] great body for the
1800s that was just unbelievable now so
did pandor pandora was also he looked
great too
and um
they're pointed out a lot of what human
potential is because
that predated the time where you could
get your hands on synthetic testosterone
so those dudes are natural now just
because those dudes look just just just
because pandora and [ __ ] santa look
like that doesn't mean that you will
look like that if you're a guy if you're
working up nah they started at the right
time they had good genetics real good
diet
um
but you could look like that if you're
taking tests
no problem
just work out
thank you very much a green spark happy
friday love the pumpkin theme
thank you i know let's get some let's
get some peanut butter whiskey
yeah let's see what that's this shit's
good we just got this randomly at abc
today try pumpkin porter
that's pretty goddamn good i like it
it's kind of soda like it's very sweet
but it's good
um also just found your new channels
jenny great content thank you very much
i'm gonna put up a new one tomorrow um i
just recorded it like an hour before we
did this show i was hoping to get it
edited today but
we were at walmart for so long but it
didn't like it didn't happen
so i'm gonna edit it in the morning and
then i'll try to get it up by noon but
we'll see how it goes
okay show them that
this is one this was 99 cents i just
grabbed it
on the way out peanut butter whiskey who
made it i don't know this is one of
those cheap ass like i said it's 99
cents okay you got that super chat 99
proof yeah let me read it again um yeah
it says happy friday love the pumpkin
theme also i just found your new
channels jenny great content thank you
um yeah i'm gonna put up a new one
tomorrow but like i said i gotta edit it
in the morning so i'm hoping hopefully
i'll get it up into good because i did
why do i do this to myself i don't know
originally the plan was cause somebody
on a couple like a couple shows ago was
like oh you should do a show jenny about
your uh scariest horror movie scenes
what
is it good or no
i can't believe that they make this
cheap ass [ __ ] taste so good
i mean there's better peanut butter
whiskeys that's like the cheap ass brand
man it's good i think i got you some
grape schnapps at one point from that
like 99 cents brand
it's even called it tastes like candy
oh my god it smells delicious
it's kind of like a cross between peanut
butter and german chocolate cake
man that shit's good
oh my god
that's delightful
it's very strong real strong well it's
99 proof
okay look show show our european friends
that [ __ ]
it's a peanut butter whiskey it is
[ __ ] awesome
they make better brands than this but
this one is actually good this one was
like just the cheap one that i grabbed
from the bin like while i was on the way
at the liquor store
but that's kind of like that's good like
you said it's very very strong you can
tell that it's alcoholic but it's yeah
it tastes like candy tastes like candy
it kind of tastes like peanut brittle
kinda to me it tastes like
german chocolate cake
you know german chocolate cake with the
damn coke yeah with coconut it almost
tastes like caramel
it tastes like caramel coconut and
peanut butter
yeah i see what you get now because it
has a buttery yeah it doesn't so much
taste like the cake it tastes like the
ice the frosting yeah
which is like the coco yeah it has like
a coconut mm-hmm
kind of kind of to it it tastes like the
frosting off a german chocolate cake but
it's hot it's it's real strong
and it's thick that's what i'm saying i
can only have like a little bit at a
time it's thick it's sticking it but
there's something kind of smooth about
it
that'd be great on the rocks
and you just just just put that on the
rocks and drink it just a dessert drink
there's a slight butterscotch flavor to
it
yeah i'll jump i'll drink some more a
minute i just you know like i said i
don't want to get harper
uh zach also says speaking of 70s music
are you guys into leonard cohen i
totally am i loved leonard cohen
i've been listening to a lot of his
stuff lately yeah um i'm i yeah i really
really like leonard cohen you probably
don't even like you probably know i
probably know some songs if i heard them
if you heard them like you don't know
everybody knows
or
everybody knows that the dice are loaded
you don't know that song
you know if you'd know it if i played it
for you
but uh yeah i love leonard cohen so i'm
just putting that out there
um also what i was saying okay so here's
what happened
uh somebody gave me a suggestion they're
like hey jenny you should do a video
about your what you think are the
scariest scenes in horror
now originally i was just gonna do okay
well i'll do like a five like a top five
like i did like on some of the other
videos on my scare salon channel
but i came up with so much [ __ ] that i
ended up having to do a top ten and then
i was like writing it today and i was
like writing these [ __ ] novels about
every single [ __ ] thing and then i
was like oh my god this is going to be
so long and then like so i got it all
written and then i recorded it and by
the time i recorded it it was like 5 30
and i didn't have time to edit it so i'm
gonna edit it
i'm gonna get up as early as possible
tomorrow because we're going out tonight
so i don't know how early i'll get up
but i'm gonna try and like edit it and
get it up but it is recorded but i don't
even know how long that video is gonna
be i'm sure it's gonna be an hour but
it should be fun i just i actually
picked 10 because i couldn't narrow it
down and i thought to myself oh [ __ ] i'm
gonna have to do another one of these so
you know
mark m says anybody ever have black
house liquor tastes like grape kool-aid
and will get you rocked i don't think
i've ever had heard of it no
i think i bought like this 99
brand this 99 brand here
i think i bought you some grape schnapps
in this brand because i bought you that
yeah because i got peanut
pb and j like vodka yeah you throw that
in there together on the rocks and then
you put it in with grape schnapps and oh
well you can either put coke in it or
you can put raspberry vodka and it kind
of makes it taste like a peanut butter
jelly sandwich yeah
yeah that's good
yeah you'll taste the butterscotch back
aftertaste
taste that butterscotch aftertaste
gotcha
man
ah i was impressed with the deck with
the jack daniels honey
yeah we've talked about that before i
really do like that they've been about
their games the jack daniels apple
it was really good that is awesome or
was it jim beam it was jim i think that
was jim jim b but i've had i think it
was jim beam honey too and jim beam
apple i think no no no no okay
uh here's what happened now i've had the
what did you say the first thing was the
jack the jack daniels
i've had the jack daniels apple and it's
delicious
now the one that we got later
was
um
jim beam apple that was good and that's
also good now somebody gave me jack
daniels a bottle of jack daniels honey
for christmas
and remember we went to that show
at
um downtown disney at the house of blues
yeah was it evanescence it probably yeah
i kind of feel like a great show live
evan s amy lee was great i bought him
tickets for the i'm not into evanescence
but i was betting
i bought him that for like christmas or
his birthday or something i loved it so
we went to the show and i was kind of
like hey i got this bottle of
jack daniels honey
for christmas and i haven't you know
busted it open yet yeah that's right so
we
so we put it in the trunk of my car yeah
and then like on the way to the show
which was at downtown disney like i said
at house of blues
we stopped and got big gulps
and then we put all of
the booze in the big gulps and drank it
while we were waiting in line i remember
that and do you remember too that we
were waiting in line like chumps
and then somebody that worked there yeah
that's right so come knew us from eyebar
right big like and we were like hey
that's that girl from eyebar and she's
like we got in front before everybody
else
and she let us in you let us into the
front yeah it's good when you know the
people it's like i felt kind of bad
because everybody else was like what the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and i'm just kind of
like she went no those are nvip's yeah
she said those are vips yeah
and we weren't we were we just like
we just knew her yeah well she knew it
was from the club from my bar we were
good to her at the club right so you
know
so at night and she worked there so she
was like
yeah she's like i'll let you in first
yeah so we got to go first we got like
right i didn't see her i know i haven't
seen her since then
was like yeah she was cute
jj said do you guys take days off
drinking we do
we don't drink every day seriously no we
drink on the show we drink on the show
yeah um we drink when we go out which is
not that often nowadays we maybe go out
like maybe twice a month at this point
um other than that not so much we don't
really
most of the time we don't every now and
then
like if it's usually if it's a weekend
night like if it's saturday night and
we're not going out or if it's a sunday
night we're not going out and we're just
like and we're watching a movie then
we're like ah maybe we'll have one drink
and stuff like that but usually we don't
usually we don't
um they're talking about uh yeah they're
talking about uh tammy said i've had a
moonshine that was pb j flavored
yeah i mean honestly the um the van gogh
vodka like i said this is the company
they used to work for
they had that pbnj
which to me i don't even think it was pb
and j i think it was just peanut butter
but i didn't taste any jelly flavor i
didn't taste any jelly they didn't have
any artificial flavorings in that [ __ ]
it was just it was all natural well
that's why it was like more expensive
like i said it wasn't american it was uh
dutch it was a good company it was yeah
they made nice [ __ ] yeah like their
stuff was more expensive it wasn't that
expensive but it was pinnacle kicked the
[ __ ] out of them
it was cheaper to taste well that's the
thing it's like they were trying to get
into that market yeah and i guess they
thought oh well we're gonna like make an
elevated version of that it wasn't like
hugely more expensive it was enough but
it was expensive enough where people
were like hey we don't care we're just
gonna be like mixing that with whatever
so nobody wanted yeah raspberry vodka
that was made with actual raspberries
that didn't quite taste as strong and as
good as the [ __ ] pinnacle which was
artificial
the way to go is that artificial
flavoring if you're gonna have flavored
[ __ ] well now that depends because some
of the artifacts some of the artificial
flavors
are not good that's true they're not
good yeah well not all those pinnacle
flavors are any good right like the damn
[ __ ] confetti
remember confetti the one with the
little [ __ ] chips uh i think they
call it confetti no i thought i thought
it was birthday cake birthday cake
that's what it is what are you talking
about birthday cakes delicious i like
birthday cake birthday cake you got sick
of birthday cake after a while
well you have to like i said you have to
know what to mix it with yeah
and just drink it at all the rocks
yeah okay the best i don't really think
that that's the intended purpose i mean
you can but and uh gummy bear
was not awesome i don't i don't even
like real gummy bears so i'm obviously
not gonna like something it's like
tastes like a gummy bear
raspberry wasn't that good the uh
only the best pinnacle flavor hands down
besides the plain plain is okay just
regular vodka
it is a vanilla
no excuse me whipped cream
whipped cream
yeah you can mix a lot with that you can
just do anything with it and i would
argue
that the company used to work for van
gogh
their best flavor was
espresso
yeah probably oh and their cherry was
good too yeah but i really liked their
espresso yeah it did you could drink
that by itself and that [ __ ] was
delicious i remember it the caramel was
good too
oh yeah that's right the caramel was
good too they had to like a lot of
flavors but they did a pb and j and the
pb j was good just didn't taste neat
i don't taste any jelly though and when
you were making the signature drink that
you were supposed to make with that like
the pb and j drink
you had to add raspberry vodka to it to
give it the jelly flavor right i kind of
feel like it just kind of tasted like
that but not as sweet another one that
they had it was uh
what was it it was caramel whiskey
something another one coke
around a salted ring and it was and it
tasted like a payday
they were can't like a payday that was
the pb and j pb j
um
i don't care i don't even think there
was another vodka in that i thought
there was i think it was pb and j vodka
with coca-cola with coca-cola ring of
salt
and
a ring of salt around the rim it was
good i liked it i don't think there was
another flavor i was making it at the
house that was years back i loved it
yeah we made some of those yeah they
were really good but like i said i don't
think they make mango anymore
because we all got laid off yeah
um
[Music]
oh they're talking about like scary
scenes now like dave says the emergency
in ringu was the scariest for me at the
time sounds quaint now because the
film's copy parodied and it's now so
iconic yeah that's the thing um
actually on the video that i said
no okay then i'm hopefully putting up
tomorrow
um i talked about the american
remake of
ring because
i don't know if this is a controversial
statement but i actually liked the
american remake better than the japanese
original but that's the only time that i
can say that like most of the time like
the japanese original or the asian
original because some of them were like
thai or chinese or whatever but um
yeah i kind of feel like that was the
only time that that happened like the
ring like scared the [ __ ] crap all
right let me go ahead and plug my my my
show you guys have found jenny jo
on twitch i have a channel called tom
13 o'clock
podcast i don't think there's any upper
cases or any apostrophes or anything
on twitch and i play video games and i
talk to you guys you guys can talk to me
more one-on-one there's a lot of times
there's nobody in there
sometimes zach will jump in sometimes
somebody else will jump in and if you
guys want to talk about something you'll
hear me [ __ ] we can talk and i'll
play video games i'm uh right i'm
playing [ __ ] laura croft old lara
croft tomb raider stuff [ __ ] legend
i'm on legend right now and i'm gonna do
anniversary and then i'm gonna do uh
underworld
and then after that i'll move on to some
other stuff like i gotta work
on um
and you never can tell i might be on
another video game you know what i mean
i might be on [ __ ] fallout you know
when you come in but really recently
i've been on tomb raider
but it's on twitch
oscar says you guys have to watch
barbarian it might be the best of the
year i've been hearing a lot about that
i've seen that coming up on a lot of
like water channels is it like a conan
type thing no no what is it i'm not sure
okay but like i said i'm just i just see
it come up on a lot of times i've heard
like a lot of good things about that
honestly i don't know if you guys like i
saw a trailer
for what's this horror movie that's
coming out like a week or two from now
that's called smile that looks pretty
creepy
it might be blumhouse i'm not entirely
sure but that looks kind of good i still
haven't seen black phone jesus christ
i'm so behind i'm so behind
uh jj says greatest horror villain of
all time ooh
man that's a hard one
i don't really like i'm i'm really
giving this a lot of thought
i don't know i kind of feel like
most
it would probably be like easy to pick
one of the big three i guess like jason
leatherface you know freddy
i don't know though because i kind of
feel like those were only really
effective and scary like in their first
movies like in the more sequels that
they made and the more they seeped into
the public consciousness the less scary
they became because they became
a thing and it became like a
i'm kind of more and i kind of go into
this a little bit on the video which
like i said i'm gonna hopefully i'm
gonna get edited tomorrow but and put up
but to me if something's going to be
scary to me it's usually going to be
something like subtle i don't usually
like
roll over like hey it's scary and i'm
just kind of like okay whatever i don't
really like like that kind of stuff so
while i liked the first movies where
like i liked the first nightmare on elm
street which actually i
get into that like a scene from it
on the video that i just recorded today
you know i like that i love the first
halloween i love the first texas
chainsaw massacre
but as subsequent sequels came along and
like the
characters became more diluted
um they became less scary to me
because i to me like
the less you know about [ __ ] like the
scarier it is you know what i mean so i
kind of feel like maybe those
because they so seeped into the public
consciousness i don't think they're
really scary anymore at least like to me
so i don't really know
about that
uh guama khan says black phone was good
i know it looked really good it looks
really good i really wanted to see it um
you know
i will get around to it
uh cam guy said the ring where the dude
is in the bathtub with the power strip
dude i'm
i talk about like some [ __ ] about the
ring
in my video you'll see you'll see there
was a bunch of scenes in that the [ __ ]
me up
there was a bunch of scenes and like i
said and i kind of get into this on the
video too i'm just kind of like look
i've like i've been watching horror my
whole life i was i came out the womb
being into horror i didn't choose it
that was just the way that's the way i'm
wired beer is getting cold okay that's
so this is probably try that one yeah
a lot better that is a lot better cold
americans drink beer cold
because it's so [ __ ] hot here
well i mean
how much is left in that a lot okay
i don't just don't rush me okay i just
didn't know if you wanted to i don't
like chug the whole well i'll ask you if
i want another
i'll ask you i'm worried about the other
ones freezing though
they're not going to freeze it's fine
okay
she's telling me when the when they beer
cans are going to freeze but it hasn't
been in there that long it can be
it's not going to be when i [ __ ] hit
that thing dude it's 7 30.
is that what happened
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] went man oh [ __ ] we're in
trouble yeah
i mean in case you're in case you're
late coming here we have to go out later
yeah although like i said we don't
we don't actually have to leave for like
two hours yeah and i already kind of i
know what i'm wearing so
that shouldn't take too long mackie mac
vr chat says i agree with tom there are
gay bodybuilders but but but there are
bisexual bodybuilders too with a big old
[ __ ] smile well there's problems
there's probably bodybuilding i'm
bisexual i'm bisexual you buy me
something and we're going to get real
sexual
need that right jenny i would love for
somebody to try that out yeah we said
what do you say okay i would love
somebody to try that out a dude
a big
big harry potter i'm not gay for pay i'm
not oh okay i thought you just said it
[Laughter]
so like a big hairy dude like buys you
something what if he buys ain't gonna
work what if he bought you a car
uh
no no no are you sure yeah yeah yeah i
got cars
[ __ ] gonna have to buy me a battleship
okay a big hairy dude buys you a battle
[ __ ] battleship yeah [ __ ] and then
you'll give it up
only only a big old gay bear would
understand that you're like a battleship
you want a badass yeah you buy me a
battleship we're going to get gay
[ __ ] i want the whole crew and
everything
[ __ ] cannons
and then that [ __ ] shows up with
a toy battleship
no i'm talking about real battleship man
stealing millions he's like hey i didn't
say it was a real battleship yeah i said
it was the game battleship right that's
right like you sunk my battleship yeah
you know
which is a good guess that's a good game
by the way dudes are [ __ ] tricky man
just let me film it okay
and then monetize that just let me film
it you monetize that
aaron's landing thank you aaron hey tom
buy jenny a drink
we ordered budget drinks we were out
buying drinks today we did thank you
very much people we went to the liquor
store thank you very much this is a very
good um
um very good super chats today
[ __ ] we're hurting for money we're
like just like you people
everybody 170 something dollars on
groceries and didn't come back with
nothing hardly he did something
well actually it was more like 200
because yeah you bought 175 worth of
stuff and then i bought i said well i'm
gonna buy some stuff just for me like
some peppermint tea yeah and we were at
walmart and we were at walmart and i
spent 25 dollars so that was two that
was two hundred dollars yeah
oh and then we went to the liquor store
yeah and spent another forty fifty
dollars yeah
like buying the pumpkins buying beers
uh let's see oscar says watch pearl also
yeah that's uh the sequel to x that came
out earlier this year which was
awesome and i think that you oscar were
the first person that recommended i
wanted to see it anyway because it was
ty west but
i don't think you watched it with me you
would probably like it actually okay x
is um
it was made in 2021 or 2022 but it's set
in the 70s and it's about it's kind of
like the texas chainsaw massacre but
like with a bunch of people that are
going to make a porno
and then they all get like picked off
one by one
and it's like a slasher and it's really
really good it was really good i liked
it a lot so pearl is the sequel
sort of
um yeah so
like i said i'm so [ __ ] behind now
oscar did not like black phone
yeah
aaron says the money's getting tired for
sure yes it is money's getting tired for
everybody
yeah i mean you know
and the thing about it is that i got
that garden going back there
well and it
we just we bought the house we had to
pay all that money for it
to set up the garden too we had to set
pay all the money set the garden we had
to pay all that money to like buy the
[ __ ]
we haven't even painted lawn mower
lawnmower i've painted literally i have
painted this office yeah and the
bathroom
and that's it i'm going to paint some of
these other rooms in here but i'm going
to do little by little
so i thought we hadn't even bought
furniture no
yeah i mean we have minimal whiteboard
furniture we had to move it anyway we
hate we have minimal friends we're
having fun though you know it's just
well to be honest it's just kind of like
i'm happy i mean to be honest
i mean
12 hours of my every day are spent in
this office so the other things don't
matter that much and i have always like
i have all my books in here i have my
desk i have like my computer my chairs
and [ __ ] like that i have a little couch
that i want it's just kind of like all
like i spend so much my time in here and
then like we have the bedroom that has a
bed and like the thing with the tv on a
gym want to paint a man cave and that's
kind of like it we don't like
we have like all these other rooms like
we have like the big living room and we
have all that other kind of stuff and
there's like a little fridge in there
and [ __ ] but it's like there's no
furniture in there there's like a couple
of chairs that we brought from the old
house but that's about it because we
never hang out in there no we going
never had any parties yet yeah we go in
there and like throw toys around for
pookie because she likes that it's all
empty yeah but it's just got i was gonna
put a bar in there because i have the
beginnings of a bar
i was gonna put a bar in there with a
sink and everything because i could
come off of this sink and i wanted some
like
retro gaming kind of [ __ ] motif with
[ __ ]
almost like you're walking into like an
arcade
or maybe a dance floor i don't not a
dance floor but like an arcade or
something just out of something people
like an old school dance floor because
like i remember back in the 80s when i
used to go to the skating rink and they
had those like cheesy and i think this
was like a hold over from the 70s
because i think this was in the what was
that john travolta movie like saturday
fever
um where they had the
the dance floors that like lit up from
below yeah
like the skating rink i used to go to in
the early 80s had that yeah what's funny
is back in back in the 80s
to do that you needed a bunch of room
the [ __ ] had to be a foot [ __ ] thick
well yeah because now you can do that in
two millimeters with [ __ ]
you know a tile that will [ __ ] light
up and do that it's very cheap now to do
that kind of [ __ ] sure
aaron says disco ball and velvet chairs
yeah
sure
i was thinking about like some buying
some retro some of those [ __ ]
you know those little one up arcade
games and have that in there um they
don't cost that much they're kind of
they're small
they're like uh they're smaller scale
but then i'm going like okay i put it
put that in there would i actually use
those probably not
you know that's what i'm saying i'm
always just kind of like i've got to a
point in my life now where
i'm just kind of like i look at stuff
and i'm just like that would be cool
like i like the idea of it but it's like
would i actually like day to day would i
actually use that yeah that would be
something just sitting around or would
it just sit there yeah
you know what i'm saying
i'm kind of like regretting
because when i like laid out this office
i'm like oh my god it's so big i should
like put a couch in here with like a
thing and it's like have i ever sat on
that couch now no
and honestly i like having it there i'm
not saying that so i just put moved in
the man cave and i can sleep on it
well the reason that i got it i was like
well what if i want to take a nap like
in the afternoon and i could just like
lay but i never do that because i'm
always too busy right so it's just kind
of like now like i've got it and it has
like this kind of like long
thing to prop your feet on that like you
can put stuff in and all and pookie is
just like torn it up well if you change
your mind just give it to me and we'll
move it in there and maybe i can use it
and then we'll put something else in
here
you know i mean i don't i like having it
there but maybe a cook station or a
workshop i don't think i've ever used it
what about a cook station to be honest i
haven't thought about toaster yeah i
thought like something that i would
probably use more yeah up here because
like i said i'm too lazy to walk
downstairs to the kitchen i have a
coffee pot up here already jenny likes
to be in her [ __ ] cocoon i understand
i totally well because i come in here i
wake up at
[ __ ] 6 30 or seven and then start
writing books and writing and then i
come in and i start working on it i
start working on the show i start
working on graphic design stuff i start
working on it so i work like
all the time like 12 hours a day every
day like i i never take a day off i
don't get weekends off or nothing
so i do all of that
so i spend a lot of time in here
now i do like
so i have the coffee pot there and i
thought to myself
maybe
i should maybe get at least like a
microwave and a toaster oven yeah
because i do have like snacks in here
like i like granola bars i have like you
know pot noodle type things like i can
heat water up in the coffee pot and i
could eat those if i had to but
it's like i think it would be kind of
cool if i had like a little kitchen like
a little break area we can do that i
mean i'll help you with that okay first
symphony and nieces i have a couple of
arcade one-ups i love them but they
don't get played that's what i was
thinking they look like [ __ ] badass
decorations the idea looks really cool
like i want all those
i'll line them up and have like a little
arcade like when i was a kid but in my
house
and i'm thinking would i actually go out
there and play those probably not
probably wouldn't see like i said i was
more like decorations like i said i
always kind of like i like the idea of
things right but then i kind of have to
think would i actually would i use that
yeah like not necessarily every day
right but enough to justify
i don't know like i said i grew up poor
so i'm just kind of like i'm very very
conscious about
am i gonna actually like use this thing
that i'm spending money on
or
do i or can i just admire it from afar
you know what i mean i can just look at
pictures of it be like yeah that'd be
awesome
because that's the thing i kind of see
stuff like because we talk a lot about
people that have stuff in their houses
like it's like hey we've got a bowling
alley or a movie theater they've never
used that i'm like do you [ __ ] ever
use it though
i kind of feel like i was big into i was
big into um urban exploration videos and
followed a lot of the really good
channels that were into that
they would go into abandoned mansions
that were new and they would tell the
story about how the person got the match
and how they lost it
and then they would show all the [ __ ]
there to be have indoor arcades and
indoor
pools with indoor
two or three lanes of bowling lanes
and uh sports themes and whole
basketball courts
and and they would just be people would
just be mystified that people could buy
all this stuff
and then lose it within you know five
years
and then in the comments section you'd
find all these contractors that build
all that [ __ ] and they'll [ __ ] tell
you the whole mansion scene
that most people that buy those don't
like them they get sick of them quick
well yeah they'll live in a small area
of the match and the rest of the shit's
shut down they never use it like i said
they like the idea of an idea
but in practical day-to-day life yeah
they would never use it they buy all
this [ __ ] have a big old mansion with
all these [ __ ] cool they'll have a
whole amc theater in there and they'll
think well i'll have my friends over to
watch this
movies at my house well guess what
all your friends got their own mansions
too and they don't want to go to your
mansion [ __ ] your imagine
you know they've got their own goddammit
they don't care
so who are you going to bring you'll be
some poor people from the hood that you
knew back in the day you know you you
can't have them there
so the whole mansion thing is kind of a
[ __ ] fraud in a certain way
and this goes back to the [ __ ] palace
of versailles
with the french king back in the 70s
it's all for other people yeah like for
display gigantic [ __ ] french [ __ ]
mansion
and and if you actually look at the
[ __ ] details back in the 1700s the
king and his wife lived in a tiny little
apartment like a normal person
inside that thing and they hated the
rest of the [ __ ] because most people
they just live in a couple of rooms yeah
yeah i mean because why would you need
you don't need like other rooms like
it's like you need a room to sleep in
your room like take a bath and [ __ ] like
that you need a room like working you
know room to chill out and you know you
need maybe like maximum like four wings
you need a room to cook in so maybe four
or five rooms that's it and some of
these mansions have these beautiful
rooms marble floors glass walls
overlooking a damn garden that had these
beautiful lights and
all these beautiful little miniature
gardens of [ __ ] bonsai trees and [ __ ]
like that and [ __ ] and it's like a
damn amusement park
you're in this beautiful you know
beautiful [ __ ] rooms everywhere they
get sick of that [ __ ] real quick you got
to hire somebody to come in and [ __ ]
piss all that [ __ ] and [ __ ] get keep
that that [ __ ] looking good and within a
few weeks you don't want to [ __ ] sit
in that damn room by yourself and all
these [ __ ] pretty lights looking at
this you know [ __ ] this
so all that [ __ ]
to do yeah
so all that [ __ ] becomes useless very
quick
real quickly
lose patience for it like i was saying i
kind of understand more
people that have a [ __ ] ton of money and
are just kind of like i don't even have
a house i just like live in hotels yeah
go from one all over the world yeah they
don't even have a house it's like i
understand that more because it's like
look they don't have any
responsibilities they don't have any
kind of because if you have like a
mansion or something like that like i
said you got to hire [ __ ] people it's
like a business to look after that [ __ ]
and you have to manage the crew or you
have to manage the person that's
managing the crew that's looking after
the butler and the butler is like the
damn it just sounds like too much
trouble the butler is the business
manager who does all shipping and
receiving and
making sure that [ __ ] the flow of all
your [ __ ] goods are coming in and
[ __ ] that uh everything's up the
[ __ ] snuff and all the bills are paid
and
taxes paid and all the inspections you
have to do on the roof and you need
somebody to [ __ ] totally think a
butler is not just some dude at the damn
door you know he's running your mansion
like it's a business
hiring and firing people and stuff
you know so it's just
and then he's doing this for a house
that you don't really that that you you
don't care about anymore you just want
to live in a little apartment
so i kind of feel like
i don't know man if it was me okay now i
do i would want security though
you know what i mean i wanted to
this is mine
yeah i do like that idea but like i said
i don't necessarily i think like the
fact of like oh i live in like 20 acres
and it's like all this [ __ ] that just
seems like too much trouble
honestly i do like the idea of a theater
though but i don't think that you have
to because i would actually do that
because i do actually like enjoy
watching horror movies and stuff and i
would like
but it doesn't have to be big i don't
have to invite friends
i don't get to invite friends everybody
just watch [ __ ] by myself just put one
comfortable chair
a little place for me to put my little
booze or my little coffee or whatever it
is
about this little snacks the theaters i
saw were about and then i can watch the
ship by myself they're about the size of
this room you can see it about 12.
big [ __ ] uh recliners but it looks
like a theater
with yeah like a million dollar sound
and audio visuals well i did um
just a couple weeks ago i did a graphic
design package for a company that
installs those yeah like installs those
kind of so you know i don't like i said
i don't need the whole shebang
honestly you could just put like a chair
or two in there and a big old [ __ ]
big and a large screen [ __ ]
yeah like i said little little place
little bar a little coffee bar that's
fine so i can just come in and like
chill out make a little coffee theater
make some booze and watch a movie
one of the theaters i saw
was on the dude's compound
it was the size of a [ __ ] say like a
starbucks
okay it had its own parking lot
you parked there you walked in
it had a concession stand
it had
it had
on the [ __ ]
entrance into the theater there was only
one theater in it
it had a
um
basically a smart tv on
this on its side
that would show you the poster of the
movie that you selected to see yeah
that's neat you know what i mean then
you went in there and then
it was the service from amc and it was
an amc theater it had amc written on it
it had amc [ __ ] like i said to me
that just seems like flexing yeah
foreign who's gonna be impressed by that
like who
that you would invite like if you're
rich enough to have that yeah who that
you would invite over to your house
would be impressive i was thinking i was
thinking why do you bother he's seeing
the movies on opening day just like he
had access and and i found out later
like no
he saw him earlier
there's a special because it's uh it's
basically an online those theaters are
run kind of like an app
online you know well now they are yeah
yeah they're like they were well this
isn't too too long ago five six seven
eight years ago
so rich people paid a certain amount of
month
to get that streaming into those little
official amc theaters that they would
buy a license for
and they would see sneak previews a few
days before other people so they were
seeing them early
by a couple days well and the thing
about it too is yeah i mean even going
back a long way
if you were
uh like for example if you were like a
big reviewer or something like that they
would send you a screener like you could
watch it earlier so you could review it
before it came out so you could like
hopefully give it good buzz like right
came out so people would go so he'd sit
there with a tablet talking to amc and
see the trailers that he wanted to see
while he was in there and uh select what
movie he wanted and while this is going
on the [ __ ] out front
outside the damn posters would change of
what movie he was watching or
and it was just like
but guess what he's the only one seeing
it nobody else gives a [ __ ]
that's weird when you're thinking about
it well the thing about like i said i
kind of feel like a lot of that stuff
it's flexing is yeah like rich people
thinking they're gonna impress people
i'm like
who like who's gonna be impressed by
that
the other rich people his friends won't
be that's what i'm saying
like the only people that would know
that you had that were other people who
had yeah were also millionaires yeah so
they're just like yeah and i have that
too so
if you all got that hit us up we'll go
over to your place where we'll watch
movies
i know we got all kinds maybe maybe i
can go to your place and we'll watch
movies in your amc theater
we just came out of [ __ ] uh [ __ ]
um right outside the edge of sanford
where all the damn
real rich houses
were [ __ ]
actually that wasn't even stanford
wouldn't it
well been um
a dress one woods road
dress wise it was said yeah but it was
even like outdoors
what would it have been
it was more like heathrow heathrow
heathrow but it was actually outside
right yeah heathrow the address said
sanford though but we were outside
stanford city limits that's like the
[ __ ] they would have in heathrow
all the ball player houses were right
there
with the mcmansions
i saw dude coming out there loading up a
big old truck he had a [ __ ] badass
trike i rode up i pulled my build up
this massive badass trike
and then i says when did you get that
this isn't mine this is something bubba
boy this is his and i was like who's
that and he goes you know who that is i
said no
because no he he plays basketball
i said oh okay i don't watch basketball
but it was the basketball player's house
i was talking i was standing out in
front of and dude was amazed
that i didn't know anything about
basketball didn't care about basketball
i cared more about the damn
trike that he was
on have they never met anybody that
didn't give a [ __ ] about no no they
never met anybody that didn't give a
[ __ ] about basketball well i guess not
because that was that's why they travel
in way different circles than me because
yeah i give
zero [ __ ]
my dad watched basketball he liked it
because your dad liked basketball says
yeah i don't like this what do you want
and i said i don't give a [ __ ] about
[ __ ] sports ball
but it was some
famous basketball player i didn't know
who that dude was so he lives there
because what he did he's leaving now
it's going somewhere else all right
i used to know a couple of basketball
players names from like the 80s
but i don't think that i know any
nowadays basketball players because like
i said i've never i'm not a sports
person yeah i don't give a [ __ ] about
sports across the street from that house
was the dude my ex-husband made me be
into soccer so i knew about that but
it's like i don't i don't know anything
across from the street from that house
was a dude
the dudes that owns ace hardware that
was his house it's a compound it's not a
house it's a [ __ ] compound
it was one of his bigger compounds and
it's [ __ ] huge
and it has a huge wall around it
you can't see it
can't see it
you guys said i have a friend who has a
12-seat theater in his house pretty good
i mean that seems like the only
thing i would like to have that would
maybe be worth it that'd be cool
maybe a pool
a small one
because i do like to swim
but like a pool indoors though that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
like i would i wouldn't mind like a
small indoor pool because i do like to
swim and i would use that yeah um and if
we had an indoor theater i would totally
use that because like i really like to
watch movies and like i watch movies a
lot so i would use that but all the
other kind of stuff i don't really see
the need for
i don't see the need for it
i wouldn't use it yeah i'm very i'm a
very very practical person it's like
it's almost eight o'clock yeah oh [ __ ]
it is yeah it is we're going to get
we're going to get ready to go yeah i
get it i gotta get ready um
[Music]
what somebody said yeah read out read
off the read up samantha says i pray tom
doesn't get a dui tonight or kill
someone oh no no no
i got a few hours we're not leaving
right right now i mean we're only
stopping because it's like i have to get
ready and i do it forever to get ready
you guys so it's like i need like at
least an hour and a half
i'm on so much [ __ ] that i sober up
quickly
so we're not even going in we're not
going nowhere yet for like an hour and a
half at least
maybe two hours
because the [ __ ] doesn't even open until
10 right so we're not we're not leaving
now we're just we're just [ __ ]
accompanying you people for a friday
night
getting you all ready
for whatever night you're gonna have
tonight which might be just laying up
there and getting [ __ ] listening to
headphones and listening to other
streamers which is nice that's good we
do it that's what we do we do it yeah we
do it man honestly like after i get done
with my work for the day like seven
eight o'clock at night
i just put on my jammies yeah and i'm
just kind of like now we're gonna watch
i'm gonna watch like whatever youtube
videos they put up with that like if
brandon put up a new one brandon ten old
or whatever then i'm like well oh last
night
i watched
the finale
of masterchef
now if you guys haven't watched it i'm
not gonna tell you who won because it
was like from wednesday night but
i'm just gonna tell you that i'm like
very happy so that's
that's the team i was on so i was like i
was happy
that they won that's all i'm gonna say
and actually like i was watching the
finale and i was like yes
i got like really emotionally invested
as you can say i love masterchef but
yeah so i watched um because like i said
i know it comes on tv like wednesday
night but i always watch it thursday
nights on hulu and so i watched the
finale last night and i was like really
excited about that and then we watched
um
the unexplained which i call the shot
show
because it's william shatner
and the one we watched last night
actually we watched a couple episodes
there was one episode about
uh
well it was kind of like the end of the
world but it was more like you know what
would happen if like a big asteroid hit
the earth it was kind of like that kind
of situation it was that and then there
was one about
sacred bones
which was good but i think i fell asleep
yeah they were walking around people's
heads
which i thought was kind of like i
thought that was kind of badass that was
bolivia
okay but yeah they had like the festival
of the skulls and they're like hey this
is get getting cigarettes and uncles
whoever and they're just kind of like
giving them cigarettes and like giving
them food i'm like and putting little
hats on them and i was like oh my god
that's adorable
but i think i fell asleep like while it
was going on and here's the funny thing
if i'm like just sitting up in the bed
watching tv and i doze off because
sometimes i do because i wake up really
really early and i'm
i don't know if i'd say i'm an
insomniac but i don't i've never i
haven't slept like a full night and i
don't remember how long usually i wake
up every two three hours
um
to either pee or for other reasons
so
i don't i don't get that much sleep yeah
sad samantha another thing is is that
the road that we take to where we're
going is basically a private road it's a
private toll road
and it's always dead there's hardly
anybody else yeah even even on which
helps
even on fridays
and saturdays it's [ __ ] dead yeah we
take a toll rate it's only it's only a
few bucks yeah and it's much quicker
than taking the highway which is free
but which the traffic is worse and
you know it's and we can go from the
country
into a [ __ ] warehouse
center in like
30 minutes 20 minutes
and
see only a few cars yeah it's great it's
a nice it's a nice drive nice dress yeah
i'm really actually glad they put that
toll right there even though it cost me
you know a few bucks
like i think it's five or six dollars
like both ways it's but it's worth it
yeah because honestly like the major
highway that's free is one
kind of out of the way you have to kind
of traffic on it and two it's
there's a lot of traffic on it and
everybody that drives on it is idiots so
you really really have to watch
um you know because all the tourists are
on it nobody knows where they're going
it's it's a whole [ __ ] show but if you
take the toll road
hardly anybody on there
it's very quiet and by the time i leave
when everything [ __ ] i'm i'll be ship
shape
yeah you're fine like i said i still
we don't have to leave for at least an
hour and a half at least longer and
because i gotta get ready i'm gonna i'm
gonna eat too i'm gonna do makeup over
i'm gonna do clothes over i'm gonna do
everything yeah uh first symphony india
says i hear and sleep thing yeah it's
like i and i can't sleep once the sun
comes up i'm awake yeah um i don't like
it but that's just what happens yeah so
i just wake up at
between 6 30 and 7 pretty much every
morning now ben frail says howard hughes
just bought a nevada tv station wait
tell him yeah so i said how are you what
i didn't say that yeah he did what did i
say i thought he was dead no
howard hughes just he bought a nevada tv
station so he could tell them what what
movies to play for him well yeah yeah
yeah okay i remember that we did a show
about how it is and show him whatever
he's playing yeah well it wasn't just
right it wasn't just the one in nevada
before he moved out to the [ __ ] sands
hotel
when he was living in california he'd
get pissed off at [ __ ] uh i think
with channel 13 i think which is kt tv
at that time if he [ __ ] went to go
take a piss and miss the part of a movie
he'd go back and [ __ ] call it he says
i missed the [ __ ] piece of that
packet on that [ __ ] and they back it up
for him all right hughes did not [ __ ]
play all right well he clearly didn't
give a [ __ ] about anybody else that was
he had money i guess if you have money
you know back that [ __ ] up
yeah yeah the whole world revolves
around you he was funny man he was
[ __ ] funny which he was he doesn't
protest the boss
and [ __ ] and he was called the boss
the boss was [ __ ] hilarious
there's a really good
biography written about it by the by his
right hand man uh [ __ ]
i'm drunk it's been so long
since i read it it's a [ __ ] black and
gold book called just called the uh
biography on a i think unofficial
biography or biography of howard hughes
it was written by his right hand man
who he recruited he was a boxer he
recruited off the street on a blind ad
to become his right hand man because he
didn't trust lawyers
and he ended up writing that book
and he tells a lot of the [ __ ]
a lot of the mythology of [ __ ] howard
has answered in that book i read it when
i was
after i got out of the army i was in my
mid-20s probably about 25 26 when i read
it it was a [ __ ] fascinating book
about a rich powerful dude who was he
was talented very intelligent he was an
interesting person good looking guy
it was another era
you know but uh in his era he was the
[ __ ] he was
and um
it's sad what happened to him
you know it is sad what happened to him
he was a good dude
multiple head injuries
well and um
no he was a good man he was a very good
man i'm just saying that it's just kind
of like one he had like a [ __ ] ton of
money which probably like put him in a
little bit of a bubble and he probably
had some
mental
issues he had ocd
that weren't really um addressed
because everyone just kind of let him
when you have a lot of money people just
kind of let you do whatever the [ __ ] you
want well people knew he was crazy but
he tried to hide the fact that he was
crazy yeah which made him more crazy
sure he had ocd and a bunch of head
injuries yeah he was trying to hide it
sure and he was [ __ ] fantastically
rich
but he was also very powerful and he was
very intelligent um
but he was
he he felt very vulnerable
and he he did he didn't want people to
think of him as a lunatic
so he had to hide a lot and hiding
[ __ ] kind of compounded his problems
yeah um his his
a lot of the problems was is that in his
era
mental problems and head injuries were
taboo well that yeah there was like a
stigma about it
nowadays it wouldn't be like yeah it
wouldn't be that way he'd be like man i
took [ __ ] seven [ __ ] major head
injuries from these airplane crashes and
[ __ ] and i've developed ocd and [ __ ]
i need help
and he would get the help that he would
need today and still be able to run his
empire yeah he was afraid they were
gonna take his empire from him yeah
that's why he didn't want it which
actually back then they may have because
i kind of feel like back then they
didn't really have and like i said it's
they call it the good old days it's it
wasn't because it's like they didn't
really have any understanding of
people's like mental issues yeah like
nowadays you have that kind of stuff
people would give you help there
wouldn't be like the stigma about it
that there was back then yeah but back
then you just kind of had to like
pretend that
there was nothing wrong with you and i
kind of feel like that compounded right
the problem there was nothing wrong with
with hughes
in general okay he [ __ ] wrecked a
[ __ ] ton of airplanes and race cars
took a lot of head
injuries he was intelligent but he had
[ __ ] frontal head injury [ __ ] uh
symptoms
and ocd
he wasn't crazy he wasn't stupid he just
had yeah
he needed he needed
management sure okay he also needed uh
to talk to people about what was wrong
with him sure
i mean i went through that okay that's
why i [ __ ] went through the whole va
thing
facing it and being able to talk about
it
and being able to overcome it
is the key to being able to heal because
it does heal up brains heal
it just takes time that's what i'm
saying that's why i think it's better to
like acknowledge it right and let people
that have either been through the same
thing or understand what you're going
through like you have to talk to them so
right
you need therapy of some kind it's like
you can't just be left to your own
devices and thinking that you're the
only person
you have to be able to say look i'm not
stupid i'm not crazy right it's just
that my [ __ ] brains got bashed in and
it takes time for this [ __ ] to heal up
yeah and and you are who you are it's
just that it doesn't [ __ ] manifest
the same way you're glitchy
but you can't really help it it's like
it's
you start showing signs of like ocd and
tourette's
all right
and it's not you it's uh
neurons in your brain it's firing
because you're trying to reroute around
things
reroute around damage from frontal
frontal brain frontal [ __ ] head
injury
front part of your [ __ ] brain i have
frontal left interventricular bright
hemorrhage from a [ __ ] frontal head
and head injury
which is uh
motorcycle yeah i got hit by a [ __ ]
military vehicle what was on post
and
got 90 of my [ __ ] active duty pay now
i'm a lot better than i was yeah i'll
attest to that a lot better than i would
you're a lot better than well you're a
lot better than you were like when i
first met you yeah that's for sure yeah
you were having all kind of problems
glitch out i would glitch out
but i was like much worse
for that first two or three years
like you just want to grab somebody and
[ __ ] choke them you get real violent
real
violent because of the frustration
you know
but like i said i kind of feel like
that's a lot of what's better about
nowadays is at least people like
understand that
howard hughes would get the help he
needed now right back then not so much
no i i i can when i read that book i
totally understood i was like yeah
but he would hide out in his own
personal movie theater for a year
pissing in bottles
and just putting it in having food
brought to him and a damn television
telephone and they played movies because
he didn't want anybody to see him
yeah
and you know that's sad very sad sad
very sad and because you keep repeating
himself over and over again
and he was waiting for it to pass
yeah and he would have [ __ ] healed up
a lot better had he been
interacting with people normally
because it's a lot harder when you're in
seclusion
yeah because you don't have any good
input right you know yeah you're only
having your own [ __ ] bouncing back at
you your own [ __ ] babson
and then movies and movies are very
shallow you have to be out there in
normal life
you're going to make a bunch of mistakes
but you got to be around a lot of people
to go no no no that's right and then not
really hold that against you of what you
said or what you did
yeah you have to be in an environment
where other people are kind of like
watching out for you but they're not
like judging necessarily
they're just kind of like understanding
they're just kind of like hey you're
[ __ ] up but we understand why you're
[ __ ] up right this is what you need
to be doing right and he didn't really
have that no so he's trying to heal
himself sure he's trying to heal him
which he would and like i said i think
that's why it's kind of sad right
because back then they didn't really
understand
the environment that you had to be in to
right get over that so i got a huge
respect for hughes
i mean he was trying
for what he was trying to do he was
trying to protect himself and his empire
he said he failed though
okay he did he failed
he ended up being a [ __ ]
shadow of his former self
living in isolation
around a security team that kept him
doped up
all right
uh his fingernails were real long his
hairs were long he was a [ __ ] invalid
but he tried
you know but like you want to blame
society more than anything else well
that's the thing at the time there
really wasn't any understanding
of mental issues and it's just kind of
like i kind of feel like that to me is a
very poisonous mindset thinking that
every single individual person yeah can
just break out of whatever the [ __ ] it
is they're doing like people need help
and you can't [ __ ] on people
for needing help because most people do
at some point in their life so expecting
somebody to
kind of just rise above whatever mental
issues they have or something like and
he had some pretty egregious like you
said like head injuries it was all like
that
and you know ocd that's kind of a pretty
big deal too that can't expect injuries
though yeah but expecting somebody to
like be able to just by themselves right
get out of that like hardly anybody can
do that
and
you know faulting somebody for
being weak for not being able to
overcome that is [ __ ] up yeah and i'm
glad that we're past that huge crash a
biplane and [ __ ] his head [ __ ]
went right through the [ __ ] front
panel of the damn pipeline
and his people were like boss you got to
go to the hospital man he had a [ __ ]
massive [ __ ] head injury all right
his concussion it was beyond concussion
you know that [ __ ] had
hemorrhages bleeding on the brain
and he's like no no i'm okay just take
me home take me home
and he was never really straight since
that and then he would [ __ ] have car
race car wrecks all the time
and his head would just
they didn't wear helmets back then and
they were [ __ ]
they were mad men trying to be badass
and and that's what i remember he had at
least four major head injuries yeah okay
and uh so it's not surprising he
actually ended up like you did because
you could only batter your brain around
so much before yeah [ __ ] starts going a
little sideways they were repeated head
injuries i only had one
he had four
and you're pretty messed up just from
that one yeah
so uh
he was the man just from from doing just
just getting done what he did all those
four i think it was at least four if i
remember correctly
it was amazing
but no no i feel for him i know what he
was going through
i feel bad for him he couldn't talk to
anybody like i said you can't right
expect in those days they would go look
here on sound we're going to take all
your [ __ ] from you and you're going yeah
so i know why he was doing that
he was sound i mean i get it yeah he was
sound he just uh needed help he needed
somebody to tell him to look man stop
glitching let's get back to this
okay yeah you did that you did good you
did good now rest you know and uh
there's a lot of stuff that they could
have given him that would have helped
him heal up
because it takes at least two years to
heal up from a head injury
and then you gotta [ __ ] that's just
the hardware then there's the software
problems okay so
the software problems could take decades
yeah that's what i mean right
people don't understand it's like this
is like some long-term [ __ ] yeah
yeah you can't just like get over that
right so i got a huge love for [ __ ] a
guy and we were good we were gonna end
the show but
he mentioned he mentioned um
howard i got huge love for howard huge
respect for howard and i [ __ ] feel
really bad for him
because that was just a bad situation i
got a taste i i had a taste for it
myself
and [ __ ] uh
yeah he's weird and [ __ ] i love those
stories too
but i understand it i understand it i
wish i could have been there
i would have been able to help him like
i said somebody he needed yeah
right to be honest yeah like i said
everybody back then just thought oh he's
being weird again yeah i don't think
they really understood no glitching out
and [ __ ] mark says had problems with
concussions due to football yeah
definitely had some emotional management
issues yeah for a while thankfully i've
improved i'd say it took about 10 years
to heal yeah football yeah i mean
wrestlers like i said he had he was an
action man he was in a
motorcycle accident yeah yeah many years
ago and got a really really bad hand
injury when i was in service in the army
yeah
that uh yeah and it took a long time
right like to get completely it's the
same thing yeah wrestlers
football players all uh soldiers us army
soldiers of course i'm a soldier too but
uh anything that involves a lot of head
injuries because explosions
ieds real bad for giving [ __ ] head
injuries
and
it takes time it takes a lot of time
yeah it takes a lot and it takes uh
understanding you have to understand you
got to be easy on yourself because
you're going to [ __ ] react to certain
things
you're going to do certain things and
you got to go like i should've [ __ ]
done that but it's okay you got to kind
of like forgive yourself that where
really wasn't me i was glitching out
because if you try to moralize what
you're doing or or what your reactions
are
you'll just beat yourself up when you
probably wouldn't have been that way
before the head injury anyway
because uh you're more aggressive
more impulsive
uh you're more apt to follow emotion
uh
you're more apt to [ __ ]
speak with before you think
there's things like that
but it's nowhere near what it was
nowhere near a lot better like i said
you're a lot better because honestly
when i first met you
when did i first meet you 2009 yeah i
think it was
so how long had you been
how long was it past that at that point
um about nine years no no no
14 years
about 14 years but you were still kind
of messed up back then you were still
having nightmares you were still having
yeah well some of that was from other
stuff too that it happened after
but uh no [ __ ] um
i had the whole monkey issue
yeah i kept [ __ ]
feeling that monkeys were [ __ ] trying
to [ __ ] kill kill me
yeah you had that you had that a lot you
haven't had that in years a long time
yeah yeah it's been a long time
and i love monkeys but those monkeys
[ __ ] were trying to eat me yeah it
was just a vision i kept having yeah he
used to freak out like all the time
you know i thought they were [ __ ]
driving me and i'd be like is it monkeys
he's like yeah yeah
yeah like when you wake up yeah
yeah i remember that that was a long
time ago yeah
come and go that would kind of come that
kind of came and went over a period of
about 10 years
got to let the end of it yeah yeah yeah
but i'm just saying like you've improved
a lot like you still have some of that
like sometimes yeah like you kind of go
stream situation into little kind of
like things every now and then jack
torrance [ __ ] like you do yeah
no
no
well i mean you still do that you still
do that but i think a lot of people do
that it's just that uh
some guys do that it's just uh you're
more volatile after head injuries you're
you're more volatile
yeah
yeah
just
ask athletes man [ __ ] footballers
those that they know they know they've
been through it that's true yeah
but like i said you're you do seem a lot
better yeah although like well you were
a lot better for a while but now that
you've gone on all this like
testosterone and all that kind of stuff
you kind of like drifted back toward
that a little bit
but not to the same extent than it was
back then but it isn't similar normal
dudes do that under the influence of
this so it's not the same
i mean i'm not saying that i don't talk
to myself and i don't do because i do
but well i don't i don't know if i
necessarily talk to myself i talk to
inanimate objects usually my computers
when they're not doing what i want them
to do like i'll talk to them like why
can't you just do what i want you to do
like it's that kind of thing but you
know so it's that all right so it's oh
[ __ ] it's 8 17. yeah let's go ahead and
[ __ ] so we have to go
press the thumbs up people everybody
everybody press like button people yeah
everybody please i only got one like on
there really only one like oh my god
nobody likes us they don't like it i'm
gonna cry everybody's talk talking about
their problems and what they gotta kill
with and this and that yeah
but yeah so we gotta go out tonight
we're not leaving for like another hour
hour and a half something like that so
it's fine i gotta go get ready i gotta
wash my face and start and burn i gotta
start over with all of this
um but you know what i mean
fix the hair i don't even know what i'm
doing with the hair i know what i'm
wearing but i don't know what i'm doing
with the hair yet so uh so yeah so
hopefully you guys had a good time this
evening with our pumpkin spice themed
show
these were actually this was actually
quite successful we had this chai
pumpkin here that's like pretty good and
we also had this
punking
nitro that was the other one that we had
oh and that uh apple
moonshine apple moonshine was [ __ ]
great delicious give that a plug and
like i said i just grabbed that
apple
i just grabbed that out of the bin it
really did buy
little check out there at abc liquor and
it comes in a jar midnight moon midnight
in shade apple apple pie midnight and it
looks like a sample jar i love that
that's the little jar that the little
spices come from the little uh
the little thai spices yeah little green
like i said it also looks like a little
sample jar that you would put like some
mad scientist [ __ ] yeah so i like that
too yeah so i would recommend that
that's really good moonshine it's very
yeah it's very strong but it's like
really really good yeah but yeah
so uh we'll be back on sunday right
talking about some movie we don't know
which one yet because it'll probably be
one that we watched tomorrow
so you guys have a good weekend up until
we see you next time thanks for dropping
by like i said please click that like
button thank you charlotte chunky
charlotte from argentina love you too
bro well hey
i love today's show thank you very much
uh so we will see you guys again on a
sunday evening good